i'm revealing myself more now to you
than i have ever done in a in a
in an interview thank you man it's been
quite an experience i'm grateful to you
it's not been a usual interview i give
three two three four interviews per week
and usually it's the same thing and
this has not been that so i'm grateful
to you thanks a lot
a couple days ago i had the pleasure of
sitting down with bernardo castro
who holds two phds one in computer
science and the other in philosophy
he also has a host of accolades so for
example he's worked at cern
he's also sold a fairly large company to
ibm
when someone like that comes along and
suggests that all we experience all that
we see
all that is traditional physical matter
is actually
taking place within the mind and that
we're all part of one mind
that is a particular philosophical
doctrine called analytical idealism
then i take him seriously and i'm glad
that i did
because i had one of the best if not the
best conversations
that i've ever had let alone on this
podcast we were scheduled to talk for
approximately two hours and we ended up
going
for almost five the time stamps as usual
are in the description so feel free to
skip ahead to whichever section you like
and i wanted to put a special thank you
out there to my patreon supporters
i do this with almost all my time so
the small amount or the large amount
that you give helps me tremendously
thank you thank you so much and please
enjoy the podcast
well i want you to know that i admire
you i've watched
your work for the past maybe two weeks
one and a half weeks
straight just inputting you into my
brain
and i think you're the most articulate
and coherent
not only of those who are idealists but
of those who oppose materialism and
physicalism in general
thank you sir when i get to the
questions about mind at large
i do have questions about well given
that mind at large
or mind itself is naturally deceptive
well how do we discern what's true from
what's not
so we'll get to that later i think as a
great overview for the audience instead
of
explicitly talking about what your views
are why don't you talk about how you
came upon your
views because most of the people who
oppose materialism or physicalism i find
they
are raised in a vedic tradition or a
buddhist tradition or hindu tradition
and they already have a predisposition
to wanting consciousness to be one
and united with all but yours isn't this
a priori
conclusion where you then looked at the
data and tried to fit it to what you
believe
i think that's interesting i think that
you need to tell the audience about
where you started and
where you got to and in there talk about
your theories so i
you know i've always been a philosopher
in the sense that i've
always asked the big questions and what
is this what is the world what is life
what is this strange condition of
being alive and having to eat and
breathe to find to fight
entropy i mean this this has always
interested me
and then i i very early went to computer
engineering school i had just turned 17
because i was fascinated by computers
and artificial intelligence
since very early and then five years of
that and you have very little time to
ask philosophical questions when you're
doing
computer engineering there's a lot to
absorb
but later on already i was in my
late 20s i had already gotten my my
first phd
um and i was on precisely what was the
computer
processor architectures reconfigurable
computing
which is you know processors that can
rewire themselves during program
execution
um which was all the rave uh in the late
90s and early 2000s now it's sort of
incorporated into into commercial
processors
but at the time it was very innovative
and then i was already in the early days
of my professional life
first few years and ai continued to be a
big interest of mine i i was even
as a hobby i was at home thinking about
you know how do you get
a processor not only to be intelligent
but to be sentient and of course i had
hidden materialist assumptions behind
that question because i thought of
consciousness of sentience as something
that you create
that you bring about that you bring into
being
and i was cracking my head about you
know how to make a computer sentient and
i was reading the work of people like um
that the finnish guy that used to work
at nokia research i forgot his name he
wrote a book called
conscious machines pentihaikonen
his his name pentihaikonen
and and he had what to me at the time
was the most compelling articulation of
how to create artificial sentience
at the time but at some point i realized
that you know
this was a nag i couldn't crack because
i was starting from wrong assumptions
and i had this
insight after reading a paper by david
chalmers in which he
discussed the heart problem of
consciousness he didn't solve it he just
framed it and framing a problem well is
half the solution
because it makes you alert to the issues
that
you you had been ignoring before and
when i read the statement of the problem
it clicked i thought i'm coming about it
from a completely arbitrary direction
i'm making
arbitrary assumptions consciousness is
not something you create
it's that within which every creation
happens including the creation of a
computer
and i am conflating artificial
intelligence with artificial
sentience these are completely different
things and we have a lot of reasons to
think that one of them will be
successful namely strong ai
but we have absolutely no reason to
think that we can create an artificially
conscious being any more reason than we
we have to think that by simulating
kidney function on my computer
the computer will urinate on my desk
and that for me was sort of the trigger
to rethink everything to examine every
hidden assumption i had
ever made to sort of completely
refurbish my worldview
along more reasonable explicit
coherent lines and it was
it was quite an enterprise
but ultimately i came to answers that
were
quite satisfying to me in the sense that
i couldn't shoot them down i couldn't
shoot down
my own answers after a few years and i
was only glad to realize that hey
the stages of the hindus valley three
and a half thousand years ago
had come to the same answers and and so
did
uh people in the western tradition plato
schopenhauer automation 2 jung
and that surely gave reassurance but i
came to my
views based on my own
painful process of reasoning looking at
the evidence examining my own
assumptions
and parting with those that were
incoherent and illogical
even if they were aligned with
the assumptions and views that i
inherited from my culture
so what are your conclusions why don't
you state the metaphysical assumptions
of materialism and how they compare and
contrast with yours
okay for a materialist there is
experience
but it's created inside our brains in a
way that nobody
can can describe explicitly and
coherently
and there is a world outside experience
which is
pure abstraction it's a world that has
no colors has no sense has no flavors
because colors
scents and flavors are experiences
created in our brain
inside our skull that's that's what
that's the assumption of materialism
and so the real world of materialism is
a world of abstraction
describable through quantities a list of
quantities such as
mass charge momentum position amplitude
frequency
uh weight and so on and so forth and if
you provide
this complete list of numbers then
you've said
everything there is to say about matter
about the world outside which of course
leaves out all qualities
but qualities according to materialism
are somehow epiphenomenal they are
created by
matter inside the brain within our
skulls so the world of our experience
for materialism exists entirely within
our heads
if you look up to the sky at night and
you see a bright star
that star in so far as it's constituted
by
color is actually inside
your skull the inner surface of your
skull is beyond
the stars as you experience them under
materialism
because the experience of the star is
supposed to be conjured up inside your
head
by your brain there is a real star
beyond your skull but that's not the
star you see
it's the thing that somehow modulates
the star
you see so that's that's the
mind twist that you have to do if you
are to be consistent with materialism in
your thinking
all the images your experience are
inside your actual skull the inner
surface of your actual skull is beyond
the room you see right now there is a
room
beyond your skull but that's not your
experience of it
it's an abstract room describable
purely by quantities it's something you
can't even visualize because if you
visualize you already put qualities in a
mix
so that's materialism and its main
problem is that nobody can provide
a satisfying account of how quantities
can
possibly produce qualities there seems
to be a fundamental epistemic
chasm between the two there is nothing
about quantities
that would allow us to deduce at least
in principle
the qualities of experience there is
nothing about mass charge momentum that
would allow us to deduce what it is like
to see red
what it is like to fall in love or to
have a belly ache
there is a correlation between these two
things
but that correlation is not amenable to
to causation it's very difficult to
coherently specify
a chain of causation from quantities to
qualities
now to me this means that we have
reduced materialism to absurdity not
that we have a problem to solve the hard
problem
of consciousness how do you come with
qualities starting from quantities
it's not a problem to be solved it just
illustrates
the contradictions of our assumptions
for me what we call matter is not the
cause of consciousness
it's what certain mental processes look
like
from a certain perspective i think the
error we've made is twofold
the first error we made was to conflate
images with the thing in itself we think
the world we see
is the thing in itself as opposed to the
appearance
the representation the image of the
thing in itself in other words it's what
the thing in itself
looks like when observed from a certain
perspective
matter is appearance it's what the thing
in itself
looks like that's why it sort of
vanishes when you study
quantum physics down to to entanglement
so that was our first error we conflate
we take the images the representations
to be the thing in itself error number
one error number two
very related to the first we try to
replace
reality with a description of reality
we try to pull the territory out of the
map
we start from an experience of the
outside world
a world of colors of sounds melodies
flavors
and then we describe that with
quantities which is fine we're creating
a map of reality
but then we say the quantities the map
is primary
it comes before the world of experience
in other words we replace reality with
our description
of reality and that leads of course to
impossible implications
but then we call it a problem and we
promise ourselves it will solve the
problem in the future
i mean it's pathetic it's it's quite
iron
ironic i mean future generations
probably will be merciless about us
because our eras are so obvious but they
are so enshrined in the culture that we
can't see them
anymore i think what's happening is that
the thing in itself is mentality
you see that every time you look in the
mirror if you're if you're sad and
you're crying and you look into the
mirror you see tears flowing down your
face
but you you will never think that the
tears are the thing in itself
that the tears are the whole story that
the image in the mirror is the whole
story
you know to say that the tears are not
sadness the
sadness exactly exactly a contorted face
with tears in the mirror
is not the sadness it's what the sadness
looks like when observed from a certain
perspective
it's the appearance the image the
representation of the sadness
but behind the image behind the
appearance
there is the thing in itself the sadness
which is a mental event a mental process
let me see if i can make an analogy
would it be like if you're watching tv a
movie or
playing a video game and you have a
monitor and the
actual data is the rgb values but then
what we can see
are explosions and faces and it would be
a mistake
to think those secondary inferences
those faces and explosions
are fundamental but the rgb values are
the actual fundamental
that's a fair analogy we have to be
careful because ultimately you're
talking about
appearances being the images of other
appearances
because the the computing going on
behind the images you see
is also material so from my perspective
it's also an appearance for me
matter is what mental processes look
like from
across a dissociative boundary in other
words from a certain perspective
and that applies to all matter but as a
metaphor or
as an analogy it's valid to go along
these lines you just proposed
okay across a dissociative boundary why
don't you explain
how dissociative identity disorder gives
rise to some of how you view the world
i i can sort of immediately give an
example from research there was research
done
i think at harvard um several years ago
they studied patients with the
dissociative identity disorder which are
people who seem to have multiple
alter personalities with different
memories different uh
proclivities different tastes uh
different ways of being
but they are in fact just dissociated
aspects of a single mind that person's
mind
now research has shown that when these
people dream
different alter personalities can
experience the same dream from different
perspectives
and they can even see their other alters
as
other avatars within the same dream i
would say that this is a great metaphor
for what might be happening right now
because
the biggest argument against this idea
that mind is fundamental
is that i can't read your thoughts and
presumably you can't read mine
so if mind is fundamental how come it
seems to be so neatly bound by
matter if matter is derivative and mind
fundamental
well i would suggest that what's
happening there is entirely analogous to
what's happening in the mind of a
patient
with dissociative identity disorder when
mental processes become inferentially
uh separate from each other when they
can't evoke one another when memories
become separate
personality traits become separate we
call it dissociation and that
dissociation is bound by a so-called
dissociative boundary
we have plenty of empirical evidence for
that in psychiatry
and we have proof that this is a real
phenomenon since the beginning of
neuroimaging 20 years ago
people with did have particular
identifiable
recognizable patterns of brain activity
that differ from those that do not have
the id
people with the id can even be literally
blind by dissociation
if an author who is blind is in control
of the body
mental activity or brain activity in the
visual cortex
has been shown to disappear and that's
not something you can fake
when you're looking around with your
eyes open and there is no activity
in your in your visual cortex and while
when another alter comes
and takes control over the body that
mental act or that brain activity
returns and is measurable again
and when you say alter you mean one of
those one of those personalities
traditionally it's called multiple
personality disorder or split
personality disorder you're just
referring to one of those
correct the way that i understand this
is that there's mind at large and then
it fractionates itself into smaller
consciousnesses that each have their own
proclivities and access to memories that
others don't much like
multiple personality disorder or
dissociative identity disorder
okay now what i'm wondering is would
this analogy still work if we didn't
refer to that person who has did
as one person so for example in your
home right now
there's you there's your cat maybe
there's some other people
and when you enter and leave i wouldn't
say that that's bernardo's split
personalities i would say he has a home
and these are different people coming in
and out so
part of the analogy you make is when we
consider
that person with multiple split multiple
personality disorder as a single
individual
split but what if we don't think of them
as a single individual anymore
we think of them as actually housing
different personalities so then
can you still make that analogy that
it's all one mind at large
look the experience of separation
definitely exists i'm having it right
now
i can't read your thoughts i can't know
what's happening in the galaxy of
andromeda
and i can't influence the thoughts of
the presidents of the world's nations if
i could the world would be
looking very different right now so it
exists
as an experience in the same way that
the different altars of a person with
the id
experience the same dream from a
different perspective
so the experience of separation
exists it would be silly to deny that
because it's a basic datum of existence
what i would say is that fundamentally
there is no separation
that experience of separation is a form
of illusion
fundamentally it's all happening in one
natural mind uh a mind that spans
uh across the universe like uh the
theoretical quantum fields in quantum
theory
um the same boundlessness is implied
there
but you see if we have a theory of
reality that
does justice to reason and evidence
i think that theory would unavoidably
point to this mental oneness at the most
fundamental
layer of reality it wouldn't invalidate
our ordinary experience because
they exist as such they exist as
experiences
but they could inform our judgment they
could inform
even our ethical systems in a much
healthier way than what's going on right
now because if you know
at least from thinking and evidence from
reason and evidence
that most likely we are all alters of
one mind
i think we would look at our perceived
enemies differently we would look at
underprivileged people in the world
differently we would
regard animal life differently
um and i think that would be a good step
forward what's special about life that
makes it such that it's its own little
dissociative identity as opposed to
let's say a computer
and then wait here's sorry to add to
that you were suggesting before that
people get well this is in the
literature people get dissociative
identity from trauma
so what i was wondering is okay so let's
say you give birth
what you've done is you've created some
a causal chain within those notes
that you had in a powerpoint slide
before people can't see that right now
but
maybe i can overlay that so every time
we give birth or every time an ant
gives birth is the universe being
traumatized
in some way and it's saying i can't
handle this let me create a new
personality
i don't think so i think that's a that's
an insta instance of taking the metaphor
too far what what makes life
special for us is that we are alive but
other than that
life is just one natural phenomenon
amongst gazillions of natural phenomena
i would say a quasar is a very very
special
natural phenomenon a very impressive one
so is a black hole
i think what we call life biology is
what dissociation looks like when
observed from a cross it's dissociative
boundary
it it it's the image of the phenomenon
to make an analogy
there was a neuroimaging study of
dissociative identity disorder that was
carried out in the netherlands where i
am
in 2014 by yolanda schlumpf and and and
collaborators
and they have shown that if you image
the activity in the brain of a person
with dissociative
identity disorder those dissociative
processes
have a certain image they look like
something identifiable you can point at
them and say hey
this is the pattern of brain activity we
see when the person is dissociated
so there is something dissociative
processes look like
in the brain of a person with the id i
would go
as far with this analogy as to say well
when the universe undergoes dissociative
identity disorder something
metaphorically related to dissociative
identity disorder
those natural dissociative processes in
the universe
also look like something there must be
something it looks like every phenomenon
in nature looks like
something when observed from a given
perspective so
so must dissociation be it must look
like
something and i would offer to you that
what it looks like is what we call
biology
that life is the image of that
dissociation
now how the first living organism has
arisen
how the mind of nature
dissociated for the first time i don't
know
could could we drag the idea of trauma
to
to to this boundless natural mind
maybe i i see something to that but it's
not necessarily the case for
for the theory to hold i would just
entertain these ideas as an interesting
extra
um but now beyond that point
beyond those initial dissociations maybe
one has happened and then died off and
then it happened again in a different
way
eventually didn't die off from that
point on
we can apply the theory of natural
evolution
verbatim to this i i'm not offering a
new science
i'm offering a new interpretation of
science from a metaphysical perspective
evolution still holds what is
maintaining the dissociative processes
is that for for some reason at some
point one dissociative process
process arose that could create another
that could maintain that dissociation
and that it could
do that is sufficient to account for why
it did for why it continues to do
because that's what evolution by natural
selection tells us
if an organism can reproduce more
effectively
it will pass on the ability to reproduce
more effectively to its
uh to its descendants and merely because
it's more effective at that
it will predominate and it will continue
to exist and so the association
has come to seven and a half billion
human beings
plus countless gazillions of other
living beings on this earth
because it's the mechanism of evolution
by natural selection
the ones that could do it were selected
and we keep on doing it we keep on
perpetuating
the dissociation because of evolution by
natural selection
anything else you add to that goes far
into speculative territory i think it's
valid speculation but for the theory
that i'm proposing to host
all you need is evolution by natural
selection
you don't need any extra bells and
whistles
you also need that consciousness is
primitive correct
i would say that consciousness is the
primitive
not personal consciousness not your
consciousness or my
consciousness but the consciousness of
nature
i would say that's the primitive and
what matter is
is what mental processes in that natural
mind
look like from across a dissociative
boundary now i am dissociated
what is my dissociative boundary well it
looks like my eyes my skin
my ears my tongue the surface of my body
and my sense organs
when my dissociative alter is
impinged upon by mental activity that
surrounds me
i register that in the form that we call
matter because again evolution was such
that our sense organs evolved
to perceive the states of the world
around us in an encoded way this has
been proven mathematically by the way we
need to encode our sense perceptions in
order to
resist the second law of thermodynamics
in order not to dissolve into an
entropic soup
so we encode information about the
outside world in the form of a sort of a
dashboard
and what is that dashboard is the colors
we see the sounds we hear
what you mean when you say that if we
were to mirror reality exactly as it is
that we would dissolve in an entropic
soup
is that carl fristen that's correct are
you essentially saying because i haven't
read this work are you essentially
saying
in the second law of thermodynamics if
you have two isolated bodies you bring
them together then they're gonna
you don't need to go that far the idea
is mathematically extraordinarily
complex it took me a long time to
persuade myself
that they were onto something but the
implication for you to understand what
the math is saying is very simple
look there are practically infinite
states
in the world out there right infinite
bits of information in the world out
there
if our perception were to mirror that
variety of states
in the world out there there would be
too much
dispersion within our body too many
states
and we would lose our dynamical and
structural integrity
in other words we would evolve into a
boiling soup
because it's too much information to
absorb too many dispersed states to
mirror
within the boundaries of our
dissociative process
which uh fristen calls the markov
blanket
he models our dissociative boundary
according to the mathematical model that
we call
a markov blanket which is mathematically
very sensible to do
so we can't mirror the states of the
world outside
otherwise we would dissolve into a
boiling soup so what can we do to gather
as much information as possible
about the world outside because it's
important to do that if we want to
survive we need we need to know what's
going on around us
the way to do that is to encode those
states in an
inferential manner you don't mirror them
all
inside you you capture what is relevant
about them
in a kind of internal dashboard of dials
what those diodes show is not the world
as it is in itself
it's not the thing in itself what they
provide is a representation of that
world think of it as a
a pilot an airplane pilot in bad weather
with clouds at night he can't see the
world but he trusts
his instrument panel so
he needs the instrument panel in order
to survive the trip
but the instrument panel is not the
world and that's the mistake we make
our instrument panel has a name we call
it matter the stuff we perceive around
us
and it's important to take it seriously
because otherwise you run on their truck
otherwise you die starving because you
don't take seriously the fact that there
is food
in front of you we should take it
seriously
but we have to keep in mind that that
instrument panel
is not the world the pilot's instrument
panel is not
the storm outside it's not the clouds
it's not the sky it's not the land
underneath
it is a representation of it and we make
this mistake we take the instrument
panel to be the thing in itself
and there it goes terribly wrong because
it leads to impossible contradictory
implications
which we can't solve because they're
just the product of
wrong thinking illogical thinking and we
label them problems and we promise that
we'll solve them at one point
and it has other even more pernicious
implications like the belief that your
consciousness will end
when you die well its state will
certainly change
it will not be dissociated anymore but
we have absolutely no reason to think it
will end
just because the image of a certain
process in consciousness has changed
you don't have any more reason to
believe your consciousness will cease to
be
then you have to to to believe that if
you wake up from a dream you'll be dead
now your dream avatar will be history
but you are not going to mourn it when
you wake up
your consciousness your conscious state
will change but you will not cease to be
as a
as a raw subject of experience
and that's the pernicious part of this
illogical road we've gone
down for for a couple of centuries now
bernardo what does it mean to explain a
phenomenon
usually even in science and philosophy
an explanation entails a reduction
so to explain something entails reducing
it to something else
can you have an explanation without
reductionism
if you redefine the sense of the word
explanation
perhaps but i think i personally
wouldn't i
i i like the association between
explaining
and reducing and i think most things in
the world around us and in ourselves can
be explained they can be reduced
the problem is that you can't keep on
explaining one thing in terms of another
forever
otherwise you will eventually go into a
circular loop
and you explain exactly nothing because
you know it's it's just
a loop it's just begging the question as
philosophers say
so at some point you you hit a rock
bottom
and there has to be something that is a
given something in nature
must not be explainable that
must be the case so that you can explain
everything else
one thing at least one thing cannot be
reduceable and i think it's
consciousness
is it possible to derive a coherent
theory from
starting with the premise of nothing of
zero that somehow becomes
more than zero i'm sure
you've gotten emails from people i'm
sure you get plenty of emails
of people's theories of consciousness
and theories of everything
and i'm sure you've come across some
that say zero's the same as infinity
from nothing comes everything from
everything goes back to nothing
so what do you make of those i think
under
a ordinary understanding of nothingness
this is possible
but i don't think it's possible with a
thorough fundamental understanding of
nothingness i think what people who
think everything came from nothing are
thinking about is that there is nothing
as there is nothing manifest
but there is potentiality so you can
define the word
nothing in such a way that it's only
applicable to manifestation
and not to potentiality and then you can
say well everything came from nothing
because nothing is just potential and
potential is nothing
but under a more thorough definition of
nothingness
i think most people would agree that the
existence of a potential
already means that it's not nothing
anymore
but the potential is something or at
least it's something to be
it's the potential for something if you
eliminate
even the potentials then i think you are
squarely
into incoherence land because there
obviously
is something we're having an experience
so there is
something manifest it is possible that
this something that is manifest
comes out of pure potential and that at
some point in
in natural history there was only the
potential
that that's possible and coherent but
you have to stick to the potential
what does it mean to exist i've heard
you say that abstractions don't exist
that numbers don't exist
that they're simply stories now here's
the way that i think about that
i can understand that let's say harry
potter to me the story exists the
characters don't
but the story exists so first of all
what does it mean to exist and what do
you mean when you say that the
abstractions themselves don't exist
in different situations when i'm talking
to different audiences i may articulate
my my words in a different way so to
appeal to the particular assumptions of
that audience
when i say that abstractions don't exist
i'm appealing to the correspondence
theory of truth which says that mental
states
are only true if they correspond to no
mental objective states
out there in the world beyond your own
mind
so based on that theory i would say
abstractions don't
exist as far as we can know because they
only exist as our own mental states
they do not have necessarily a
corresponding state beyond
our own mentation or beyond mentation in
general
so in that sense abstractions are just
that the abstract are abstractions
they do not correspond to an objective
state of affairs outside mind
now of course the abstractions exist as
such
they exist at abstractions but
most people today they take the
abstractions
further they will say well the
abstractions exist not only as
abstractions
but they correspond to something that is
not
itself an abstraction and that's where i
would say
what reason do you have to believe that
[Music]
theorizing in science is useful as a
predictive
tool the the elements of our theories
like elemental subatomic particles we
have never seen a higgs boson for
instance
we haven't even measured one what we
measure are the results of the decay of
the higgs boson and higgs boson exists
for too short a time
to interact with any measurement
instrument but we talk about the higgs
boson as if it existed why
because nature functions as though
it existed and that's enough for you to
predict nature's behavior
and develop technology you don't need
any more
than convenient fictions that prove to
be predictive
in practice in order to develop
technology and prove the power of
science to come up with explanations
uh forward explanations and retroactive
explanations but we cannot
lose from sight that these are stories
that happen to have predictive power
nature behaves as though the higgs
existed
as though quantum feuds existed which
are pure abstractions pure theoretical
abstractions
but when we take the philosophical this
is no longer scientific step when we
take the philosophical step to say
this theory is literally what nature
is and when you talk about being about
business now you are in metaphysics
territory
science makes no statements about what
things are science only
says how things behave not what they are
when you take the theory and you say
nature
is that is a higgs boson is a quantum
field
now you are taking a philosophical step
which may but
may not be correct and which science in
any case
cannot either prove or disprove because
it only makes statements about behavior
so i caution against this runaway show
of abstraction
that we are engaged in today we take
these useful fictions of scientific
theory which we should take very
seriously because they are very useful
we take them to be literally what is and
there we can go
terribly and drastically wrong what
theory of truth do you subscribe to
you said that when you're speaking to
some audiences you conform to what their
notion of truth is and i
assume that what you're equating is what
exists is that which is true
at least for this conversation and you
reference the correspondence theory of
truth do you hold the correspondence
theory of truth
for your own personal view of truth no
uh i think
oh what do i hold in to
in my own mind i would say all that
exists is mind
and everything else are the results of
mind deceiving itself
is that not correspondence that what
exists is mind like our concept of mind
corresponds to something called mind
correspondence
would be when you make a link between a
mental state and a non-mental state
so that's what the correspondence theory
of truth would say
and since i don't acknowledge the
existence of any
non-mental state i think all states are
mental then
rigorously speaking i have to part with
the correspondence theory of truth
but there are we need a useful
theory of truth because otherwise we
open the gates to all kinds of nonsense
if we can't differentiate the things we
normally label true from the things we
normally
normally label fiction we open the gates
to all kinds of stupidity
and nonsensical and conspiracy theories
which are very popular today
do i think we have to do that no
absolutely not i think we should stick
to
a coherence theory of truth
in other words things that fit
with the data and our reasoning can be
said to be true
as such to be true as things that fit
with observations
and reasoning notice that i'm not making
a metaphysical inference from this i'm
not saying that these two true things
exist outside mentation
i'm just saying that they are true by
virtue of
fitting with our reasoning and the
evidence we can
access and that allows for a theory of
truth that works
in every instance in practice
now what theory of truth do i hold for
myself so i'm not talking about
interaction of human beings and social
life and politics and economics not
about any of that i'm talking about what
i hold true when i
put my head on my pillow alone at night
in the darkness of my room well with my
girlfriend next to me but
when i am alone in the sense of in my
own mental space
the one theory of truth i hold as
fundamental is that
there is only mind not my mind there is
only mind
and everything else are the products of
that mind
and within that richness of mental
creation we can classify some as true
because they
fit into the coherence of the edifice of
reason and evidence that we've built
and we can say that others are untrue
but the others
do exist as experiences
um a schizophrenic person
does have the schizophrenic experiences
they exist
as such as experiences they just don't
apply to the collective so
when a schizophrenic says i've met jesus
and he touched me and blessed me i would
say
fantastic hold on to that it's an
experience you've had
and it is true as such nobody can take
it from you
but when that person comes and says and
because of that i am the emissary of god
on earth and
should all follow me then i would say no
now it's untrue because it doesn't fit
with
with the coherence of our edifice of
reasoning
and with the evidence that we have
access to
and therefore from at the collective
social level that is
untrue not by virtue that it is
metaphysically other than the truth
but by virtue of not fitting the scheme
of things
i see i see so we're all part of this
one
for people who are listening it's called
mind at large at least that's what you
call it
we're all part of this one mind do you
think this mind mind at large can be
grasped
mathematically with mathematical
concepts because
when i was listening to you what i'm
thinking of is
it's easy for some people to say that
they've
skirted the heart problem of
consciousness by simply positing
consciousness
but to me well that's like saying i've
explained
the mildly positive nature of the
cosmological constant by saying well
it's mildly positive i just
posit that as a given and to me i'm like
well that doesn't explain it
the fact that i experience green saying
well green is a primitive
to me doesn't explain it so can you help
me out with that
well i wouldn't even say that green is a
primitive i would say
phenomenal consciousness is a primitive
and green is a particular pattern of
excitation of phenomenal consciousness
in the same way that a particular
pattern of ripples
is an excitation of the lake there is
nothing to the ripples but
the lake and yet you can discern
different patterns of ripples you throw
a stone on one side of the lake it will
look different than you
throw a car on the other side of the
lake the lake will ripple
differently there will be
differentiation arising from the unity
of the lake and at no point there will
be anything
other than the lake the ripples have no
standalone existence they are patterns
of movement
of excitation of the lake but within
that context we can talk of diversity
many different types of ripples ripples
of different height different speed
different length different shape so i
think green is a ripple
sourness is another ripple falling in
love is a ripple
these are different patterns of
excitation of the one substrate of
existence which i think is
universal phenomenal consciousness this
doesn't deny the emergence
of diversity on the contrary it grants
that diversity exists
by virtue of this multiple possible
patterns
of excitation of the one entity that
truly exists
and i would say that all mathematics
that has
ever been done has done
none other than to describe those
ripples of minds the patterns of those
ripples
the archetypal patterns according to
which
those ripples tend to unfold um
we you know we have resonance theory
which is a beautifully informative
theory applicable to all kinds of
situations it basically says that every
object has certain modal frequencies of
excitation frequencies in which it
preferably oscillates
like if you put somebody in a swing and
you push that person if you push that
person
faster than the swing wants to go the
person will stop moving because there
will be
a destructive interference but if you
push that person in the exact same
frequency that the swing wants to move
it will build up and there will be
resonance and
builders in japan protect themselves
against earthquakes
precisely by trying to not be in that
in that harmonic of of of the earthquake
or otherwise it will resonate with the
earthquake and
it will crumble i think what
mathematics is showing us is that mind
itself
has some harmonics it has some
preferred frequencies in which it tends
to oscillate
better than in other frequencies jungian
psychologists would call it the
archetypes of the collective unconscious
the templates of behavior and feeling
that tend to manifest more frequently
and mathematics
models that everything mathematics has
ever done was to model the patterns of
excitation of mind it has never done
anything else so if you're asking me ask
me can it do that i would say
obviously it can because it has never
done anything other than this
okay so what i was saying is that these
union archetypes they don't seem to be
modeled mathematically they seem
amorphous
and ill-defined but yet you're saying
that undergirding existence are these
ripples
of consciousness now ripples are
obviously easily modeled mathematically
so i'm assuming you're using ripples as
a as a metaphor
of course then is there hope to model
jung's archetypes mathematically
again i think we've never done anything
differently but let me preface this with
a disclaimer i'm not saying that
mathematics can only model
human psychology of course not it can
model the world it has been
spectacularly successful
at modeling black holes and and
predicting the behavior of black holes
it has been spectacularly successful
at modeling the microscopic world of
quantum physics
so obviously mathematics models the
models the world out there
which is precisely the mystery
physicist eugene wigner wrote a paper in
1960
titled the the the effect the the
mysterious effect
effectiveness of mathematics to model
the natural world
he uses the world miracle 12 times in
that paper because
for him it's a miracle that our
logic our mathematical
tenets are so incredibly accurate
at modeling the world outside our own
personal minds
why should that be the case and there is
no good reason why that should be the
case and
wigner was in wonder that mathematics
could do that that somebody
in the in the solemn isolation of his
armchair
could think up equations that turn out
to predict quasars and black holes and
quantum
phenomena it's incredible why is that
the case
just to complete this i would say that
it is the case because both our minds
our personal minds and nature at large
they both
rest on the same thing on the same
natural mind
the the inanimate universe we study and
describe with math
is just the appearance the image the
representation
of transpersonal mental processes out
there
which also comport themselves in
preferred ways
in archetypal ways if you want to
extrapolate the jungian definition
so at the ultimate sense i would equate
nature with the archetypes of the
collective unconscious
but by doing this i'm not saying that
mathematics is not applicable to quasars
and black holes i'm saying that quasars
and black holes
are themselves the expression the image
the way transpersonal archetypal mental
processes
appear when observed from our
perspective
so defining archetypes this broadly
you may think it's a trick it's a bit of
a trick but if i define archetypes this
broadly then i would say mathematics
models the archetypes
because it's modeling the patterns and
regularities of nature
when you do not have regularity then you
have
randomness and that's not modeled but
well it actually is modeled by
mathematics but not in a precise way
you can measure certain overall
properties of randomness but not the
particular instances of
every aspect of a random process so
mathematics of course only models
regularities
and i would say that all regularities
both in our personal mind and nature
at large are regular by virtue
of being the expressions of this
fundamental harmonics
of this one mind underlying all
existence
the archetypal manifestations of this
one mind it's by virtue of being
archetypal
that they are regular otherwise there
would be no regularity if there were no
favorite modes of excitation no
preferred modes
of behavior no resonant frequencies no
harmonics if you will if there weren't
any of these
there would be nothing for mathematics
to model because nothing would be
irregular it would be just random noise
obviously it's not so what's mathematics
measuring
by my own definition it's modeling the
archetypes of all nature the inner
archetypes and the outer archetypes
they are one and the same thing is it
possible that there exists this random
noise that's not
patterned and it's just that because
it's chaotic we don't even perceive it
it's not within our realm
you know there are many things we
thought in our earlier scientific
history that were random and now we know
that they are not random at all it's
just that the cause of chains involved
they're so complex that we can't keep
track of them
so when we throw a coin we know that
there's nothing random about that
it's it's about the air flow it's about
the weight distribution and the center
of mass of the coin
it's about the particular angular and
linear momentum that you imparted on a
coin when you threw it
but it's impossible to keep track of all
that so we say well the
the coin throw is random well it's not
fundamentally random
it's epistemically random in the sense
that we can't keep track of it but it's
there
now i would say that every single time
we figured out that what we thought was
fundamentally random was just
epistemically random
there is one exception today and that's
the particular outcome of
one quantum process we know that when we
take a set of quantum
events together that set is predictable
it has some statistical characteristics
that are predictable
but a single quantum event is completely
and fundamentally unpredictable today
now i would dare to say that
this again is an instance of epistemic
randomness
not fundamental randomness it's just
that we don't have the theoretical
apparatus in place to convince ourselves
that it's just that we can't keep track
of what's going on so we think it's
random
but i don't think it is fundamentally
random i don't think randomness exists
fundamentally
i think the very concept of change is an
appeal to epistemic limitations in other
words when we don't know what causes it
we say it's by chance
but it's not by chance at all it's just
that we don't know what the causal chain
behind that was
and it may be that there are patterns
and regularities in nature that exceed
causality
that don't fit into our current
definition of causality
so you could say that certain things are
a-causal but not that they are random
it's just that
they are obeying patterns and
irregularities of a different nature
than the linearity of causal chains
there may be
resonant patterns of vibration
sympathetic
influences in nature things that look
alike that tend to happen together
even though they are not connected by a
causal chain of events
what jung called synchronicity so i'm
open to the idea that there is
more to the patterns and irregularities
of nature
than the processes that fit into what we
would call causality
but that is only because our definition
of causality is limited
which gives value to the word you know
if we make this definition too broad
then the word means nothing but what we
call causality
may not be the whole story but i think
whatever is the whole story it's an
expression of the patterns and
regularities inherent in nature
and therefore inherit in the mind of
nature and in our own minds and that's
why
wigner's miracle is not a miracle at all
that's why mathematics can describe the
world
both are rooted in one and the same mind
obeying the one and same
at the same archetypes before
we went live we were talking about how i
had some experience
with let's say some greater reality
maybe or not it may be and
it it provoked extreme anxiety in me
and then you told me well kurt i mean
that what i thought could be true but it
also could not be and the mind is
exceedingly deceptive
so what i'm wondering is so is mind
deceptive or is it just our narratives
about the sensory data that becomes
distorted or
is mind at large somehow
constitutionally deceptive
and if so then how do we sort out what
is
true from what's not what do we use as a
barometer to guide
our life is it divine revelation well
you already said well
we have to do away with that the thing
is
most of the world we think we live in
arises from our inner narratives from
our inner
storytelling um we don't see the world
impartially at all
uh we tile it with narratives with what
we tell ourselves is going on
and i think the deception that is the
prime directive of mind
is in weaving these narratives it's not
deceptive
when it comes to what it is in itself
because it's what it is it cannot
deceive itself other than by telling
itself
a wrong story about what it is but it
cannot be
deceiving itself in the sense of being
something other than what it is it is
what it is and that's what it is you
know that
there is no escape from that so in that
sense there is no deception
whatever is is has always been
and whenever will always be the problem
sorry here's one way that you can
recover that it is what it is and also
that it's that it is necessarily
distorted
because let's imagine consciousness is a
circle i know this is foolish but let's
imagine it's a circle and then it has
ripples that come
out somehow maybe there's another law on
top of this that when the ripples come
back to you
that chain is somehow
not what it was when it left so you
could all you could recover that it's
necessarily
that it's necessarily deceptive and i
think there's much of
the buddhist traditions that say
something like this now you will know
much more
so there you go i'm not an expert in
eastern philosophy at all actually
um look there are certain coherence
constraints that can
base a useful practical theory of truth
um but those coherence constraints
necessarily necessarily arise out of
some
collective engagement so we can say that
given our stories our collective stories
about what is reasonable
and what is evidentiary we can eliminate
certain things
as untrue and i think that's entirely
valid not only valid it's crucially
necessary for social life
otherwise it would be completely
dysfunctional but i think
at the bottom of it all there is just
mind being mined and then telling
itself narratives about what it is and
that's where the deception occur
uh um it is in the narrative it seems
like it's unadaptive or unless
it is adaptive like you're saying it's
highly truth it's incredibly adaptive
you could say that without these
narratives nothing would be real
it is the process of self deception that
creates
any sense of objectivity and
concreteness and
reality uh without those narratives
you're always in always resting in that
awareness that whatever is arising is
just you making it up
you see the one mind in nature is making
it all up
for it to have a sense of reality in in
in other words and that's our intuition
about what's real
is that which exists regardless of
whether you believe it or not
that's our intuition about what's real
for that sense
to exist you have to have some kind of
narrative that creates boundaries in
nature that creates
that which i am not and which unfolds
independently of what i think
believe or prefer if you don't have that
there is no reality there is no sense of
reality there is only the one mind
knowing
that it is the only thing going on and
that whatever arises it's thinking it up
which probably is the ultimate reality
but it's not a comforting reality and is
it
i call it the when you glimpse that
i call it um
the english word escapes me the vertigo
of eternity
which is better described as the vertigo
of timelessness uh
because it is a verb is that akin to the
void that some people it's nietzsche's
voice but
yeah yeah when you look long enough into
it it stares back at you
um it's what is that staring at you i
understand that you can have the
experience of the void what
do you mean when you say that the void
stares back at you i know you're quoting
nietzsche but
what does it mean in your model i'll
tell you what i think
nietzsche meant okay what nietzsche
meant is that if you stare enough
in the into the void of your own
mentation
it seems to acquire a life of its own
and become a separate agency
and as such it stares back at you it
sort of
splits off from yourself and acquires
objective reality
jung insisted that the archetypes were
the objective
psyche and so it appeals to this sense
of separation of this sense of
boundary creation that that creates what
you are and what you are not
that which is inside and that's what is
outside that which is the self and that
which is not the self the subject and
the object
and reality depends on the separation
our sense
of what is real depends on it because we
intuit reality as that which does not
depend on us
i think ultimately there is no such a
thing there is no such
reality the real reality is that its
mind making it out all up not randomly
but by giving expression to its own
favorite patterns of excitation it's all
its own harmonics because that's what it
can do by virtue of being what it is
and then we place the narratives on that
and that narrative creates the quote
a reality of subject and object
which is extremely useful
the richness of experience would be much
less
if if this were not the case it is
a sense of separation illusory as it may
be
that creates the richness of existence
that create
it creates it creates the human drama it
creates drama
is this mind at large akin to what in
other religions
they call god and can you pray to it
does it intervene
i don't think um we have good reasons to
think of
the mind underlying the rest of nature
in other words the mind that's not my
mind your mind
the mind of my cat the mind that is not
in any living being in other words the
non-dissociated segments
of of universal mind i think we do not
have good reasons to think of this
non-dissociated segment which i
call mind at large we don't have good
reasons to think of it
as self-reflective
as capable of metacognition of capable
of having the thought
oh i am having this thought i think it's
more akin to my cat it has experiences
but it doesn't think of its experiences
as such it's not self-reflective it's
not metacognitive
so from that perspective i don't think
the unfolding of nature is the result of
a premeditated plan
drawn in the very beginning of time and
now carefully unfolding under
supervision i don't think that's what's
happening i am a naturalist i think
nature is unfolding the way it is
because it is what it is
it can't be any different i think
interpreting it as
mental which i think is what's actually
going on only informs us that this
unfolding is instinctive
rather than premeditated so i wouldn't
pray to it as if it were
a thinking human being in the sky
with a plan and making explicit and
thought through
decisions about the fate of every human
being
i think i i think that's that's not how
stuff is happening that's not what's
going on i think it's unfolding
via its natural archetypes its preferred
ways of unfolding that set
setting an intention i think
can influence the world
for the exact same reasons that moving
your arms can influence
the world our mental activity leaves a
footprint
in the world by having being here our
environment
is what it is or wouldn't have been if
we were not here
i mean to speak in physical terms in in
other words in in the language of
representations and images
we occupy a volume in space if i were to
suddenly disappear
air would rush into that volume of space
and probably create a sonic boom i don't
i don't know
it would make a thundering noise because
that's exactly what thunder is it's air
filling in
the vacuum of overheated air left by
lightning
so our very presence in the world
changes
the world and i think this is very
obvious when it comes to our physical
influence in the world by building a
house with our hands
by moving around but i think the same
type of influence um is plausible
when it comes to the deepest layers of
our mind which may not be as dissociated
as our ego is
in other words it may have more commerce
with the mentation around us
so if you set a deep intention through
prayer
i do think it is plausible that you may
get an effect
but not for the reasons you may think
you may get an effect
so it works as if but the mechanism is
exactly then yeah
maybe naive but maybe effective in the
sense that things work as if it were
true
where does morality fit into this and
purpose
i think purpose can be teleological
in other words purpose what we call
purpose may reflect a fundamental
archetype in nature
so it could be a natural archetype um
let me phrase it in a different way
self-knowledge i suspect
is a natural archetype in other words
there is an intrinsic drive
in mind including mind at large towards
self-knowledge
uh i think it's incredibly incredibly
plausible that this is the case because
it seems to be the case for every single
living
living being there is a drive to know
about ourselves what
are we we have this need to identify a
place
in this grand scheme of things for what
we are we care deeply about it
and raising our self-awareness has all
kinds of positive
effects so i do think
self-knowledge as purpose has a
teleological root it reflects a
fundamental archetype of nature
it exists because nature is what it is
by being what it
is it wants to know itself merely by
virtue of being what it is
now morals are a different story
i think morals are very important
to guide our social lives to make our
social lives function if in in a
complete moral vacuum
we would be completely dysfunctional
there would be no basis for cooperation
we'd be killing each other raping each
other
and there would be only chaos and
destruction and we would go nowhere now
none of us wants that if you look deeply
into yourself you see that even if you
think you want that no
you're just rebelling against something
else or you're angry
with yourself but deep deep deep inside
we all want some form of
functionality we want to go somewhere we
want to evolve in some sense
learn or find out something or express
something
and morals are important for that but i
don't think they are archetypal
i think morals are a product of an age
and a culture
in a sense they are an invention we
create them but we create them for very
good reasons very practical
reasons to make our social life
functional
but i don't think they reflect something
fundamental
in nature i think they're human
creations important ones
and just so you and also people watching
understand i'm not
an idealist i'm not a materialist i i
don't know what i am
i just say i'm a somewhat foolish
filmmaker
floating in a void unmoored and looking
for
anchorage so that's why yeah
well it's also destabilizing at the same
time
okay when i hear that you say well we
all want the same thing
and i don't think history shows that i
think that you may say well
unc in our deep deepest drives we all
want the same thing but that's somewhat
unfalsifiable because then if someone
says
and acts as if they like to murder and
they like like genghis god said to put
the head of his enemy on a stick
and rape the enemy's tribes that's my
idea of morality something like that no
that's not what they meant just briefly
to clarify
what i meant is that deep inside we want
we all want
some form of order but the form of order
that you may want may differ from mine
and we may go to war
about it but none of us wants complete
inertia chaos
hitler didn't want it genji's khan
didn't want it
nobody ever wanted complete chaos they
just had different
notions about the order they did want so
what i meant is
we all want some form of order different
forms but we all want
some form of order none of us wants
total and complete
chaos yeah to me that's another way of
stating that we all want something
because then to say it's a thing means
that it's discernible which means it has
a boundary which means there's some
order to it but then i don't know if
that's saying much
because it's like saying we want
something it could be anything and yes
it can conflict but you do agree that
you want something yes we can both agree
we do want something
it doesn't say much kurt but it does
explain the emergence of morals it's
enough
to explain why morals arise at all
because
some order and the reflection of that
want is what we enshrine in a moral code
okay okay so i can see how morals
could have developed evolutionarily and
that they can conflict
what i was wondering is if there's a
divine order or if there's some
objective morality you seem to say
well maybe not but if we want to
function together then
that's akin to a dance and we call that
dance morality
there is certainly a divine order
because if there weren't there would
have been no successful science
there is there are patterns of
regularity in nature
that we can capture with mathematics and
which help us to predict things with
extraordinary precision
so there is natural order absolutely i
think
this is archetypal order it is what it
is because nature is what it is
um but moral order
is a specific type of order that seems
to govern
behavior now i haven't i have not ever
been able to
identify a archetypal moral order
in nature killer whales orcas
they fool around with sea lions before
eating them so
torture for the sake of play chimpanzees
can organize gangs to murder order
chimpanzees in their own tribe
nature is a blood bath your backyard is
a blood bath
and cutting earthworms in pieces while
they are still alive
i mean do you see a
moral code embedded in nature i don't i
see order in nature but it's not of a
moral quality
um it's much more fundamental than that
it's a much
lower floor of the building it's much
closer to the foundations
and i i wouldn't attribute the word
morality to that in any sense that the
word is used
in conversation i think morality what we
mean by it is something that we create
ourselves
in order to facilitate social
cooperation
for the achievement of our preferred
form of order
now different people may have different
preferred forms of order that's why
different cultures at different times
have different moral codes
because they need to organize their
behavior along different lines in order
to achieve
their particular sense of the order that
is desired
there is always some desired order
enshrined
in a given moral code but that order and
the moral code differ
across time and space so i don't see
them as fundamental i see them as
practical pragmatic very useful very
important
human creations nature itself has order
but it's not moral
it's a much more raw form of order much
more fundamental
bernardo i don't know about you but i
gain a lot of insight from watching
intellectuals
talk about one another comparing
contrasting it's almost like a battle of
the gods
so i would like you to comment i have
quite a few intellectuals
written down yoshibak dennett
jordan peterson daniel hofstetter
hoffman ray kurzweil even
so let's just stick with yoshibok for
now how do you
view his theory of consciousness where
do you see him
being mistaken or misguided um
i'm not sure the name is familiar i have
heard the name
but i don't really know much
okay well he would say like and i'm
paraphrasing that computers can be
conscious
because all that consciousness is is a
simulation
so consciousness it's we have it
backwards we don't have that you can't
simulate consciousness
we have that only a simulation can be
conscious and what consciousness
is is the computer or whatever
computational infrastructure
underlies this universe in his model its
computation like wolfram would say its
computation
at its core whatever it is it's then
making models and telling stories
and what we experience as consciousness
is this machine telling a story
simulating what would it be like if so
and so happened
look i'll criticize what you described i
don't know whether you have been
accurate or complete probably
so i cannot pass a judgment uh giving a
personal description
the name joshua he's familiar there was
a guy who sort of trolled me a few years
ago
on my website i'm probably not the same
guy but the name is familiar
i would say the following look i have a
friend who calls this kind of position
the pinocchio theories of consciousness
like consciousness is pinocchio's nose
i think this is at the same level as
saying that consciousness
is the involuntary wiggling of my left
big toe
it's completely arbitrary because it
doesn't
link the word back to what it we know it
to be
consciousness is experience so to say
that consciousness is a simulation is
just as arbitrary as to say that
consciousness is the wiggling of my
pinky
it not say whatever you want but it
doesn't have any meaning
it's a syntactically well-formed
statement that that is completely devoid
of
semantic foundation um
look because we've made some
fatal errors in our thinking we take
images to be the thing in itself
and we replace reality with descriptions
we are forced
into reductions and reductions to
absurdity reduction at absurdum
um but we don't want to acknowledge that
we've reduced our thinking to an
absurdity
so we label it a problem and then we
give ourselves the freedom to completely
abandon
our sense of plausibility when it comes
to consciousness
a sense of plausibility we take very
seriously in every other situation
for instance i can simulate
kidney function on my computer
accurately
down to the molecular level
but that doesn't mean that my computer
will pee on my desk because we know that
the simulation of the phenomenon doesn't
matter how accurate
is not the phenomenon but people who
think we can create sentient computers
they think that by simulating the
particular patterns of information flow
in the human brain
they can create a machine that is
conscious well that's entirely
strictly equivalent to saying that the
computer simulation of kidney function
can pee on one's desk
it's absurd it's very very sophisticated
stupidity and we don't see that
because we backed ourselves into a
corner of absurdity by making those
initially
wrong postulates about the nature of
reality
mistaking representation for the thing
in itself and mistaken reality for a
mistake and description for reality so
since we are
in absurd territory already anyway and
we don't want to admit it we give
ourselves them the freedom to conjure up
this ridiculously silly stories
that are peddled by ray kurzweil for
instance
these are the pinocchio theories of
consciousness i think mine is better
consciousness is the wiggling of my left
big toe
okay so let's let's not straw man any of
the people who believe in the illusory
nature of consciousness
i for one haven't heard or grasped a
coherent theory that says that
consciousness is an illusion
and so for me when someone says well do
you believe consciousness
is an illusion i can't say no nor can i
say yes because i imagine that if i was
to
articulate it back to daniel dennett
let's say that he would say that's not
what i believe at all
so if you don't mind helping me out and
explaining what do people mean when they
say
like daniel dead in particular because
i'm sure they're variants of this so
let's pick dennis
what do you what does he mean when he
says consciousness is an illusion
and separates yourself from that this is
rich territory so
let me try to get my bearings here to
operate
fairly in these waters
you could say that when people claim
that consciousness is an illusion
what they mean is that consciousness is
not what it seems to be
that is coherent but it does not solve
the hard problem of consciousness
because the heart problem of
consciousness is not what we think
consciousness is it's about the fact
that
there is experience at all so by saying
that consciousness is not what it seems
to be
doesn't solve the heart problem because
even if it is something else
the fact that you think about it the
fact that you experience something
is already an instance of that thing
that you can't explain
so the proponents of the consciousness
as an illusion theory
they are either incoherent
or they are irrelevant
because if you say consciousness is an
illusion because it this is not what it
seems to be well you're a coherent
but you're not solving the heart problem
actually you're not doing anything
at best you're making a statement
related to cognitive psychology
we think wrongly about a whole number of
things we think we see the entire visual
field in high resolution
or in fact we only see the very center
of the visual field in high resolution
and because we are always moving our
eyes scanning the visual field to create
the solution that it's in high res
well there is that illusion could we be
wrong in our
explanations about what consciousness
actually entails
well we very well could be wrong about
that but it doesn't matter
because if there is any experience
regardless of the story we tell about it
if there is any experience at all
then we have the heart problem so they
are either
incoherent absurdly incoherent because
you know
to say that consciousness is an illusion
in the sense that it doesn't exist
is directly incoherent because it's the
only
instance of an illusion in which the
illusion
itself is already an instance of that
which you're trying to say doesn't exist
because if you're deluded or eluded
about something
that very illusion is an experience
an illusion happens in consciousness so
if you're trying to say that
consciousness doesn't exist because it's
an illusion you're
flagrantly incoherent and if you're
trying to say that it's an illusion
because
it doesn't seem what it seems it is not
what it seems to be then fine you're not
incoherent but you're irrelevant
you're not contributing at all uh to the
problem
and now if you press then it on that and
and this is not even an opinion it's
well known he is slippery
he will never give you a final answer so
what do you think his motivation is for
that do you think it's nefarious or that
he's just
simply misunderstanding something no i
don't
neither i don't think he's nefarious i
think he truly believes
what he's saying and what he believes is
that
we are missing something important that
would just make the heart problem
disappear
and he's trying to suggest a direction
where to look for that something
but he hasn't found it and he's the
first to admit that he hasn't quite
pinned it down he's just suggesting
direction well i would argue to you that
he's walking in a hall of mirrors
uh that's something he's looking for it
doesn't exist it's not there
but because he doesn't want to part with
a certain world view
he wants to keep space open for it to
keep the possibility open that one day
we may
we may find it this is not nefarious
it's just human
it's a human foolishness and
and human committed human commitment
to the stories with which we identify
ourselves publicly
it's very hard when you're publicly
identified with a narrative it's very
hard to 30 years later
when your life has been lived already to
say well i was a fool
and that was wrong because then you're
telling your own ego i wasted my life
and no ego wants that and there is all
kinds of psychological subterfuges
ego defense mechanisms with the
technical name
in which you will trick yourself into
not confronting that and keeping the
possibility open
for that which you committed your entire
life to
and that's why true revolutions only
happen
in the hands of younger people who are
not already committed
and who are truly more open-minded and
are not plagued by this
autonomous psychological mechanisms that
take her eyes off the ball so do you
believe richard dawkins when he says
well one of the best stories of my life
was when someone pointed out to me why i
was wrong
or pointed out this professor and then
that professor who had worked on that
particular theory for 15 years said
thank you i appreciate you telling me
that i was wrong and now i can abandon
that and he was saying that as a
as a virtue so do you think that richard
dawkins
and people like him who are materialists
are in a sense virtue signaling
about their willingness to abandon their
preconceived notions even if it's been
around for 20 years
you see it as like no no you should
abandon this preconceived notion that
goes back 200 years
i think when it comes to what i would
call small theories
things that we are not fully invested in
if somebody proves us wrong it's truly
welcomed it happens all the time in
science
but i think when you have committed your
your own
self to a certain perspective and you
have invested your life and career in it
and you're recognized as the very face
of that position
uh i don't think anybody not even me
would be truly happy to be proven
wrong i think it's a it's an egoic
catastrophe
it's something that will lend you in a
therapist's room
in no time if you're open-minded and
will lead you to drugs and suicide if
you're not
so uh i i i think that that's the
self-image
uh dawkins has it's what he wants to
believe
about himself but if the theory in
question is not a small theory but
the metaphysical theory of materialism
then i don't think
he is being honest to himself he may be
honest in the sense that this is what he
actually thinks about himself
but i think he's deluded as most of us
are about our own
inner psychological dynamics so he's
pretending to be
infinitely malleable but he's saying
well you can trim the edges but
don't cut me off at the roof i don't
think he's being malicious about this i
think he himself believes this
about himself so he's not being
dishonest in a malicious way but i think
he
may be deceiving himself if this is
indeed what he said
yeah i see okay let's talk about douglas
hofstetter who has a brilliant brilliant
book i think it's
both mine and yours favorite books or at
least one of them and there are only a
few books that i keep posting
yeah and then there's one more that you
should check out called
meta magical fema's as well these ones
haven't read yet
yeah it's they're full of essays that
are that are more digestible than girdle
escher rock
so what's douglas hofstetter's view on
consciousness how does it arise in his
view
and then why do you think that's
incorrect what are the problems with it
okay look let me first sing some praises
to douglas of slaughter that book by him
godo asherbah
is a monumental achievement
of human intellect it's a book to be
literally
in awe off and he what wrote that
apparently
most of it when he was like 27. yeah but
that's usually the case
yeah when we are at our peak which
happens very early on we peak very early
when it comes to that kind of
intellectual work and we peak very late
when it comes to wisdom
and that's a distinction you have to
keep in mind wisdom peaks
late intellect peaks early
and that that's a monumental intellect
to achievement the different threads it
has managed to weave in there which is
reflected in the title
are fantastic and and it's very seducing
his story and
okay to try to summarize that book in a
conversation is nearly impossible
or it's effectively impossible so what
i'm about to say will be an injustice
but
we need to do we need something to guide
our conversation so
i'll summarize it unfairly in the
following way
he uses the idea of strange loops
that's the name he uses strange loops
and what basically
these are are self-referential loops
things that refer to themselves and you
see that in godot's proof
of his incompleteness theorem you see
that in the canons of
bach compositions and you see that in
the paintings of uh
asher the the dutch
draw artist drawing artists more than a
painter
in which things sort of self-refer there
are strange loops of self-reference
which are very difficult to wrap one's
mind around because of the
self-reference
self-reference is very difficult to fit
into an intellectual drawer because it
seems to be a hydra
whenever you think you got it under
control other heads pop
elsewhere and sort of catch you from
behind because of this self-referential
loops
and he constructs this he helps you
build this
intuition about the strangeness of
self-referential loops
in a majestic way it's a true
master of conveying that intuition and i
think the book is monumental all the way
close to the end
because then his last move is like a
fall
from the precipice it's like he climbs
the world's
tallest intellectual mountain just to
throw himself into into the abyss at the
very end instead of standing in there
and cheering he just throws himself into
the dark abyss because
the idea he tries to convince you off is
that
somehow because of all the weirdness
of these self-referential loops somehow
that relates to the origin of
consciousness
and this is an appeal to complexity
to hide an impossible intellectual
position
does he just say it's somehow connected
or does he give more of a
connection than that he he
i would say he claims to give a more
direct account i don't see that direct
account i see an arbitrary jump
from the acknowledgement of something
very strange
to something related to consciousness
which is not even consciousness because
what he's appealing to when he tries to
explain consciousness
is not phenomenal consciousness he's
appealing to self-reflection
self-reflection is one particular
configuration of consciousness one
particular modality of consciousness
phenomenal consciousness is is the
problem here
once you have phenomenal consciousness
you certainly can account for the
emergence of self-reflection
out of a mind that already experiences
and i would grant to you
he succeeds in that in a highly poetic
and intellectually sophisticated way
he succeeds in explaining the the rise
of
self-reflection but he doesn't succeed
in
explaining that right from
non-consciousness he explains it right
by
assuming that there is already
phenomenality to begin with
okay so if i understand this correctly
you see him as explaining
self-consciousness
given consciousness but he doesn't
explain consciousness itself
yes but he may use the word
consciousness in the sense of
self-reflection or self-conscience
or it's conflating and that happens a
lot in neuroscience that happens in
psychology
it happens a lot it's widespread
philosophers have tried to
help and you know make sure that these
words have coherent meanings and
distinctive meanings but people make a
mess but
let me bring to your attention again
that the problem is not self-reflection
or self-consciousness the problem
is that there is experience at all that
qualities can emerge
from quantities from mere numbers and
abstractions that is the problem
now how something that already
experiences can then develop the ability
to cognize its own experiences
explicitly
in other words to tell itself oh i am
having this experience now
that's a trivial problem a relatively
trivial it's a problem for
cognitive neuroscience cognitive
psychology
it's not a problem of a metaphysical
nature
and and the whole path
that that is followed in that book
has to do with self-reflection and and
and then it
but it doesn't explain phenomenal
consciousness at all and he's a
hofstadter is not the only one
uh to to make this conflation it's it's
all over the place so
i think he doesn't explain phenomenal
consciousness at all and
to talk about um ray kurzweil again in
his 2005
book the singularity is near
he appeals to pure complexity to explain
consciousness
which is similar to the strangeness of
the loops that hofstadt therapeuts to
and what you see consistent behind all
these different
attempts to reconcile consciousness with
materialism is an appeal to complexity
and appeal to an
unknown and to to lay bare what i think
is going on there to you it's like
saying that
if we add enough legs to a centipede
centipede it will eventually fly
because at some point there will be so
many legs so man you can't even
visualize you can't picture it with so
many legs it's so complex so amazing
it will fly well no it will not
because adding legs does nothing er
to to the ability of flying so it
doesn't matter how many legs you add it
has nothing to do with flight
so when it comes to consciousness
material is to acknowledge that a few
neurons talking to one another is not
conscious because now we can measure
all the parameters that are of relevance
and they're all quantitative
so there is no reason to think that that
would create qualities right
there is nothing about a series of
neurons
sending electrochemical impulses to one
another that contains the redness of red
or let me say the greenness of green
because the neurons are not themselves
green
and and electrochemical impulses are not
green
so greenness doesn't arise from that we
all know that
but we say but if you just put enough
neurons talking to each other
in such a complex way that you can't
even think about it you can't even
visualize it then green has emerges
no it doesn't for the same reason that
the centipede with more legs doesn't fly
or even appeal to an unknown well my
issue would be
maybe it does in some way but you
haven't explained it at all you've just
said it's complex
therefore the quality of it said nothing
but you see this is what keeping
materialism alive
it's not it's extra planetary power it
can't explain experience and therefore
it can be said
that it doesn't explain anything because
everything we know we know by virtue of
experiencing it in some way
but it's being kept alive by trying to
keep
its plausibility open in other words the
effort
is in not admitting that it's dead the
effort is in saying well
we can't explain it now but we may
explain it in the future in some
incredibly torturous lines of argument
that actually don't touch many of
the important issues but sort of create
a smoke screen so the survival of
materialism now the efforts in that
direction are focused on creating these
intellectual smoke screens and they are
just that their smoke screens
incoherent appeals to the unknown
incoherent abuse
to complexity to try to keep that story
alive right
um then the tricky part is that it's not
unjustified because before there was
plenty that we thought was magic and we
couldn't explain
and then slowly materialism has
explained that explain that explain that
so now
they think well consciousness is just
one of those that we deem to be magical
somehow
or at least the spiritual types or at
least they view the spiritual types as
deeming it as much
another conflation materialism has never
explained anything
at all what has explained things is
science
and science is not a metaphysical
commitment science is metaphysically
natural the problem is that so many
scientists conflate the two
that we created this cultural fable that
science is inherent materially science
is not
science allows us to predict the
behavior of nature
so if our predictive models work in the
sense that we predict that nature will
do this
if this and this happens and then nature
goes ahead and does exactly that
okay science works and we can develop
technology on the basis of that
predictive power
but none of it depends on an
understanding
a correct understanding of what nature
is
whatever nature is is not in this
whatever nature is it's behaving in the
way it's behaving
that its behavior is not in dispute it
does what it does we can predict it we
can model it we can write equations
about it we can prove
the effect and effective effectiveness
of those equations through experiment
and none of that says an iota about what
nature is
the metaphysical question is the
question of materialism materialism says
nature is essentially non-mental
it nature is essentially quantitative
independent of mind right yeah but it's
not science
science uses the quantities to build
predictive models not to say that
nature is quantitative science doesn't
make the statement doesn't need to make
the statements
so i would say materialism never
explained anything
all it did was to carve out in the 17th
century
to carve out a space for science uh
different from the space that scientists
had to grant to the church
the soul of man belonged to the church
and if scientists tried to
wander into that territory they would be
burned at the stake
so there was a very very good reason to
leave mental space alone to the church
because you see the word for mentality
in greek is psyche which is a same word
for soul
so so mentality consciousness
back in the 17th century they were the
one in the same thing
so scientists needed to differentiate
from that to carve out a space where
they could work without being burned
alive
the invention of materialism
served that purpose it was not
an explanatory thing well you could say
it was handy in the sense that it
allowed
the scientist to to separate himself
from the subject of study
by by thinking of his own mind as
encapsulated in matter
his beliefs about the outcome of
experiments wouldn't uh
impinge on the experiment so whatever he
believed
didn't matter only the result of the
experiment so it had a psychological
role to play that helped scientists
become more neutral more impartial i
would grant that it had a
social political role to play to allow
science scientists to carve out a space
for themselves
without the risk of being burned alive
but it has never
never had an iota of an explanatory role
it can't have because all that we know
to happen we know by virtue of
experiencing it
and materialism does not explain
experience it explains exactly nothing
it has been a socially and
psychologically useful fairy tale
but one we have grown out of we are
better than this we are better than to
hide behind complexity
to hold on to an into an untenable
intellectual story that has reduced
itself to absurdity but we don't admit
it we call it the heart problem of
consciousness
and in order to safeguard our own
self-image
and the commitment we've made publicly
to a certain narrative
um and it's a shame that it's playing
out this way
have you heard of dennett's quinine
qualia
i have heard of it uh i've read some
about it but i don't consider myself
uh knowledgeable enough of the subject
to criticize or comment intelligently
essentially what he's doing is
dismissing that we have qualia at all
that's probably the case for a
particular
very a restrictive definition of qualia
that then it holds in his own
mind um he's not the only one to do that
um there are others there's his little
followers
that that hold to the same point of view
but if you engage with them and you try
to really know
make explicit what all the assumptions
are all the term definitions what
they're actually saying
you will notice that what they mean by
by qualia
is not pure
raw experience it's a theoretical
construct
to to say that qualia don't exist
is the most self-evidently absurd
statement conceivable to human thought
because it's to deny that there has ever
been an experience that you have ever
had
now if you confront the danette side of
things i debated one
online via twitter several times last
year
keith frankish is his name we even had
an exchange of
essays on the iai the institute of art
and ideas we had a very public
and contentious debate um
you see that they don't deny the rawness
of experience because
they would basically be committing
themselves to the lunatic asylum if if
they did that and they're not that
stupid they are not stupid they are
intelligent enough to weave a complex
enough intellectual web that they
themselves get stuck in it
and cannot find their way out and and
that's the dark side of high
intelligence
you can weave with high sophistication
a web that is so complex so
sophisticated
that you yourself get caught in it and
you're unable to find your way out
um the simplicity of the problem eludes
them
the simplicity of the meaning of the
word qualia for
most of us that are not caught in in
torches intellectual abstractions is too
simple
for them to even discern for them to see
the simplicity of that
and that is raw simple experience if
you're hungry that's qualia
you see a red apple that's qualia you
think about your
immortal soul that's qualia whatever is
not quali is fundamentally beyond your
ability
to know even your abstractions are a
form of qualia as such
as abstractions in your mind you cannot
escape that
so by proving that something else
that they mean by the word qualia
doesn't exist
they are either incoherent or they are
irrelevant
because either they mean by qualia what
you and i mean
and then it's absurd what they're saying
obviously quality exists
or they mean something else we're
strictly defined in a highly
sophisticated and torturous
philosophical manner and that thing that
they define indeed doesn't exist
but it's completely irrelevant because
it doesn't have any bearing on the heart
problem
bernard i gotta use the washroom super
quick sure if you don't then do you mind
quickly explaining to the audience
because they're probably thinking about
this
why is it that if this is all dependent
on the mind then why is it that there
seems to be object permanent so you
leave the room the object still
okay you can explain that thank you yeah
so
when you say that um as an idealist and
we say that um
the whole world is a mind we don't mean
that it is only in your mind or in my
mind
alone we grant that there is a world
outside
our personal or individual minds
separated from us by a dissociative
boundary
and and it's that dissociative boundary
that characterizes us
as dissociative alters of this one
natural mind
and the image of that of that boundaries
our skin
our sense organs and the external
appearance of our
self is the image of this dissociative
boundary that
separates ourselves from our environment
in the language of reality of mind i
would say
that dissociative boundary is a
cognitive inferential
isolating layer between our internal
mental processes and the mental
processes
unfolding in mind at large now i can say
exactly the same thing
in the language of representation in the
language of appearances in the language
of images and say
your skin is what keeps your inner
metabolism separate from
nature outside your body i'm saying
exactly the same thing using two
different languages
so when i say that always in mind i
don't mean that
it's all mental processes within your
dissociative boundary within our alter
in your personal conscious in their life
i don't mean that
what i mean is that nature beyond you
nature outside of you is mental as well
it corresponds to some transpersonal
mental processes
that hold their own state and that's why
when you park your car in the garage
when you arrive home from work
and you go to sleep and you're not
seeing your car next morning you go back
to the garage and your car is right
there where you left it
why because the state mental state that
corresponds to
car has been held intact
in a transpersonal mental process that
does not depend at all
on your personal cognitive state whether
you're awake or not
that state is held outside of you as an
individual
as an individual mind but it's not held
outside
mind as a substrate it is also mental
but it's not your mind that's what we
mean by it
when you talk about your viewpoint
sometimes i see you hold up a pen or a
cup and you say look mine is actually
the intuitive
viewpoint because i'm saying this exists
whereas the materialists are saying that
this is
some apprehension that's possibly
distorted it looks nothing like this
okay
now how does that compare with douglas
hoff sorry donald hoffman's work
which says that this is a virtual
reality it seems like it's incompatible
and then also there's someone named
thomas campbell i don't know if you've
heard of him
i don't know about his work but i have i
have heard a lot about him yeah
i haven't read his book yet what have
you heard about him
he was a physicist who did a lot of
meditation in his early days and came up
with a whole theory
of nature based on his meditative
insights that have
when you get the chance it's like 400
hours of
time to spend in this one thick book but
if you ever do read his book called my
big toe
that's thomas campbell's me and you have
to have a conversation about that
because i want to know what you think
about that so regardless
he has a similar viewpoint as donald
hoffman which says that this world is a
virtual reality
okay what do you say to that
it's completely compatible with what i'm
saying don and i
dovetail with each other almost all the
way to the end
only at the very end very end there is
one tiny little thing but important
where we diverge but it's not a
fundamental divergence i think we will
see eye-to-eye on that he's open to it
very shortly we'll see eye to eye to
that on that look
uh the materialist will deny this bottle
in the sense of its concreteness its
color
its texture because the materialist will
say well that concrete
concreteness you feel is entirely inside
your head
it's created by your brain there is
something outside that corresponds
to a concrete bottle but it has no
qualities including the quality of
concreteness
it doesn't have texture doesn't have
temperature smoothness
color none of that it does have
properties that correspond
to this concreteness but they are not
the concreteness so this bottle exists
only in my head
so the materialist denies the reality of
the bottle i experience
outside my own mind they deny that
reality they say the bottle experience
exists only in my mind
what is outside has no qualities now i
disagree with that
because i think this concreteness this
of of this bottle exists
as an experience and is that experienced
inside my head
or is it not it's not
because my head too
is something that i perceive
if i had no mirror i would never see my
head
so i cannot i do not say that the
experience of this bottle
exists in my head because in my view the
epistemic status and the ontological
status of my head is exactly the same as
the bottle
look they exist side by side i am
perceiving them
side by side obviously the bottle is not
inside my head
as an experience right what i do say
is that the experience is of the bottle
in the experience of seeing my head on
the screen right now
they exist in my altar but my altar is
not a head
the head is part of the image of my
altar
do you see what i'm trying to get to
it's a subtle point it's very
obvious if you're not immersed in the
assumptions that we inherit from culture
if you can stick your head out of that
it's obvious what i'm saying but because
we are not
able to look at it from a neutral
vantage point it seems subtle
my mental life is not in my head
my head is a partial image of my mental
life
so what space is this all taking place
in mind space
i'll get there the experience of this
bottle
is entirely in my mental life
this experience does not exist in mind
at large
there are mental processes in mind at
large
that correspond to the experience of
this bottle
but this bottle is my dashboard it's not
the world outside
there is something outside experiential
also mental process
that corresponds to this bottle on my
dashboard
but it is not this bottle this bottle is
the appearance of it
it's the representation of it as
an appearance as a representation
the bottle exists in my mental life
alone
as an as a dissociated altar
because it's my altar's representation
but it's not in my head because my
mental life is not in my head
my head too is a representation
so one representation is not inside
another representation they both exist
exist in my in their mental life i think
part of the confusion for some people
who are
listening or watching who consider
themselves to be materialist or
physicalist or
are without knowing is that when someone
says this exists in your head
sometimes what they're trying to say is
this exists in your experience and what
you're granting is that is the case it
does exist in my experience
it doesn't exist in my head because head
refers to a physical location in
space-time
that has a brain and so on and that is
not only
a semantic linguistic distinction it's a
crucial distinction when it comes to
your understanding of your place in the
world
because now it's not all in your head
you are not restricted to your head
your head is a representation of mental
processes that you identify yourself
with
but those mental processes are not bound
in space
look you can only bind your own mental
processes in space if you say that they
are inside your head
because your head is what exists in
space
space is the canvas of representations
if you're not talking about
representations you're not talking about
space and then it makes no sense to
regard yourself
as this tiny irrelevant minuscule little
thing
in a huge universe because you're not
talking about representations anymore
you're not talking about space
you have to think extra spatially which
leads to
entirely different perspectives about
your worth
about your role in nature about what you
are about what's important
and what's not so it's not only a
linguistic distinction
i have a dutch word now in mind because
it's the same as the english word
stopping mining head but stopping that
means to put something inside another
pushing mind inside our heads
is one of the most pernicious
implications of the materialist
worldview you can
possibly think of because it has
limited our being uh to irrelevance and
we are proud of it we think we got rid
of our hubris
no we have enormous hubris in other ways
we have
the hubris to think that our theories
can explain the whole universe
that's hubris in another form but we are
proud to have made ourselves
into nothing because we sort of put our
own minds
inside our heads limited it in space
look this you have that hubris by saying
that you can explain the entire universe
with your theory
i am interpreting the universe
my explanatory power is not one that
gives you control
over nature what does that is when you
predict nature's behavior and then you
can put nature to
to work for your own benefit and that's
what science does
science is no we stole fire from the
gods we can put the universe to work for
our benefit
why because we can predict nature's
behavior do we need to know what nature
is
not the least a five-year-old kid can be
world champion in a computer game
without having any understanding of what
the game is all the hardware and
software behind that
the kid doesn't even know it exists
doesn't know what it is it doesn't care
does the kid know need to understand
that to play the game no the kid needs
to understand the behavior of the game
and then you can come master you can
master and win the game that's what
science does
it tells us how the game works it tells
us how the representations behave
it allows us to predict the
representations so we can play the game
and win
this is the hubris of control and this
is
stealing uh fire from the gods what i am
doing
gives us no control whatsoever it
doesn't allow us to control nature it
allows us to make
peace with our own nature and our role
in nature
what's that minor place where you and
hoffman disagree but you think that
you're going to win him over at some
point
for for dawn's theory to hold you always
need at least two conscious agents
because the dashboard for him arises
from an interaction
so you need at least two conscious
agents so he cannot go
down to one because his mathematics will
not work if you go down to one
and i my view is that that's profoundly
dissatisfying because it seems to
arbitrarily require
the existence of two completely
unrelated things
why would there be two completely
unrelated things existing i mean it
sort of it violates my my whole sense of
plausibility
and my argument to him is that you he
can make the mathematics work
even if it goes down to one one
conscious agent
but then he has to use the mathematics
of vibration which is what underlies
string theory m theory if you have only
one field you can still recover
all complexity from that by imagining
that field
as a vibrating surface a
multi-dimensional hyper-dimensional
surface but a surface nonetheless
that moves according to different
patterns of excitation if you have that
you can recover any complexity any
arbitrary level of complexity you need
to make sense of nature
by applying the mathematics of vibration
as opposed to the mathematics of
interaction
and you can reduce the mathematics of
interaction
to the mathematics of vibration if you
have two wavefronts that come and
interfere with one another
constructively of or destructively
that's an interaction but you can reduce
that to the one surface where
those wave fronts are are moving so you
can reduce the mathematics of
interaction to the mathematics of
vibration
granted things become a lot more complex
and that's what m theory is struggling
with there are so many free parameters
in that
horrendously complex mathematics that
they cannot make any
discerning prediction it's too complex
to wrap one's head about it
so i think it's in practice laudable
that don is restricting himself to the
mathematics of interaction
because that makes his work and the work
of his team
more feasible it allows us to make
progress
so i applaud that but i also think at
the very end
for them to take that very last step
which will not happen in our
lifetimes or in the lifetimes of our
grandkids this is far off
but to take that last very last step
to the most part parsimonious view of
nature we can have
we will have to translate that
mathematics into the mathematics of
vibration which m theories ahead
is is already ahead of us doing except
that they think of this
hyperdimensional brain uh
they call it a brain of m theory they
think of that as something that is not
mental i would argue to you that
that is just an aspect of mentality what
they are describing is mind
space itself is mind you want to
visualize
mind at large visualize it as empty
space and all the things that
pop into existence within space as the
patterns of vibration
empty space is the lake when it's when
it's not rippling
objects and all the dance of existence
are the ripples of that lake
mind is empty space and empty space
there is only one conceptually
so i think don't well his successors
and the successors of his successors i
think ultimately
we will arrive at that conclusion from a
scientific perspective
i think philosophy can arrive at this
conclusion today the limitation is that
philosophy cannot predict behavior
and dawn if he can
port the theoretical apparatus of
science to the mathematics of conscious
agents
he will be doing
a fundamental step a fantastic step
forward in our understanding of nature a
step that philosophy alone cannot do
science needs to do that so i applaud
him
i just tell him when we're having our
one-on-one conversations that you know
at the end of the day you will go to
vibrations because philosophically
metaphysically speaking that's the only
tenable position for you to be in you
have to go down to oneness
otherwise you have an arbitrary
postulate
of the existence of completely
independent things interacting with one
another why the hell would nature be
like this you know
anyway where do you disagree with deepak
i'm sure you overlapped ninety percent
well
my relationship with deepak you know
we never compared notes uh on an
analytical perspective
um because i don't think he's really
interested in that he's interested in
enriching people's hearts people's
intuitions he's interested in helping
people
leave more healthily a more
conformity with natural laws he is
interested in reaching
uh the common people for whom all these
intellectual abstractions are just that
irrelevant abstractions
which is the vast majority of people and
and
and i think he is he has a much more
significant impact in the world much
more not only because
he's more famous than i am no i don't
mean that i mean that
he is speaking about things that are
more relevant
to most people than what i am speaking
about i think the relevance of what i'm
doing to most people
comes only later because our cultural
narrative
makes people depressed based on the
wrong reasons they they adopt a
materialist
story uh uh and that that leads to
existential nihilism
um and that story is we have no reason
to believe it to be true so ultimately i
i'm doing this for people's hearts as
well but it's indirect and in the case
of deepak it's much more
direct so i never compared notes
analytically with him all i can tell you
is that
i never heard nonsense from deepak
chopra
um i see him as a wise person
uh who is trying to do something good uh
for the world
um certainly a very positive
force in the world and nothing that he
ever said
contradicts my thinking and i and i
think the other way around
applies as well i will let him speak for
that but
nothing he he ever said contradicts my
view of reality on the contrary
we seem to have a very natural intuitive
understanding we don't need to compare
analytical notes to know that we are
both
going down the same the same direction
you know
we're both trying to achieve the same
thing in different uh
ways one more immediate than the other
but there is this
natural resonance that doesn't require
us to bother about
comparing notes if you know what i mean
i like him a lot
where do you agree or where do you agree
and disagree with jordan peterson
i don't know about i don't know enough
about peterson to
to pass judgment i'm very happy to pass
judgment i don't refrain from it i
am known for for being sharp in this
regard
but i i do want to pass judgment only on
things at least
i think i know enough to pass judgment
on
and i don't know enough about peterson i
know he's a jungian so
that's a point of commonality so he has
my sympathy based on that alone
where do you disagree with jung i don't
i'm publishing a book in a couple of
weeks titled decoding young's
metaphysics in which i try to make
explicit
what jung's underlying metaphysical
thought was throughout his
psychology works i think jung was a
flat out idealist he said the collective
unconscious
and matter in nature are one and the
same thing by which he meant one is the
image of the other
matter is what the collective
unconscious beyond your personal self
looks like when
observed from across a dissociative
boundary which
defines our individual mind um so i
don't
agree with him i think jung
and there are two intellectuals i
consider the
most important of the 20th century and i
i'm not
quite sure which one but i think thomas
kuhn
and koyung in the 20th century were the
two most important intellectuals
they provided the most indispensable
important crucial insights that we
needed then and need now
perhaps more than back then
so i i i regard him with
the highest respect i think he was a
sage he he saw
way beyond what most people could see
um and i put kun on the same level with
him not because kun has the same
breath and depth of insight
as young jung had such a breath of
insights about
every aspect of the human condition it
that it's unmatchable
i put i put thomas kuhn together with
him because kuhn had
one insight about one thing that was
so foundational so devastatingly
important that that
one thing alone is enough for me to put
him on the same height
as jung but if you are care if you care
about breath
and relevance for the human condition in
our everyday life
jung is unbeatable and he went so deep
that the vast majority of his peers
cannot even conceive
of what he saw and he he did see it he
didn't hallucinate it
he saw it right there he pinned it down
but most of his peers are
too short-sighted uh to even take that
level of depth seriously they think jung
was
schizophrenic maybe he was
which doesn't contradict what i just
said
what do you make of penrose's
orchestrated objective reduction
have you heard of his collapse theory
because he's one of the materialist
physicalists that don't think our qualia
and truth and other concepts are
arbitrary but in fact they're
members of a platonic world somehow
embedded at each space time point
yeah look let me preface it by saying i
have great respect for sir roger i think
his nobel prize this year
was too late it should have come a lot
earlier
and i hold him in the highest regard he
and i
were featured in a dutch documentary
only of a couple of weeks ago
i have great regard for him
but i do sense and that may have to do
with
the time during which he had his peak he
had his prime
which was a time in which even a
conversation about the plausibility of
anything that's not materialism
uh was not conceivable you know now we
can have this conversation you know you
and i can
have this conversation today and
although the majority majority may
disagree with me
the reasonable majority will not
consider me a nut case
because they see that well there are
things that materialism can't make sense
of arguably everything so
you know the discussion the debate is
legitimate
but it was not in the time when sir
roger was in his prime so
i'm prefacing this this way because i
don't want to get across as somebody
unfairly critical of him
but i will say this i think
a lot of his work tries to reconcile
a materialist mode of thinking with the
recognition
that there are things that can't be
reduced to materialism
and he tries to accommodate it all in a
sort of trialism
it's not even dualism so for him there
is the physical world there is the
mental world and then there is the world
of the platonic values
and they are not the same and all three
of them are fundamental
and i think that's a step forward from
naive materialism
but in another sense it's a step
backwards because it violates the
principle of parsimony
i want to talk to you about that because
this principle that we should be frugal
with our assumptions
i don't buy that necessarily i'm more of
the feynman mindset that nature is as it
is maybe it's an onion maybe it's of
infinite complexity
so who are we to impose this miserly
quality when it comes to the axioms
we don't know so why why is it that i
understand how it's intellectually
more comprehensible as well as it's
fun and beautiful when it's smaller but
i don't see any reason why
nature itself shouldn't be slightly more
complicated than just one
oneness this is an excellent question so
let's bite this bullet head on and not
hide from it
science does not need to make many
assumptions
ultimately does not need to make any
because it's studying the behavior of
nature
and when it comes to the behavior of
nature you don't need to assume you need
to set up an experiment
and nature will answer your question by
behaving in a certain way
and the question is settled if you can
repeat that experiment done by different
groups
then you ensure that you eliminate the
subjective aspect from it
and there is your answer you don't need
to postulate or speculate or imagine
answer has behaved that nature has
behaved in a certain way
that gives you the answer so when
feynman said
use the onion metaphor it would have
been more accurately
if i could paraphrase him to say if
nature behaves like
an onion then the onion is the best
predictive model
and that's how it is that's that that's
how things are
and there is no need to postulate
oneness because the behavior
is best predicted by imagining it as
anonymia
and i agree completely with him when it
comes to science
the assumptions have a very very
restricted role
make the experiment if you have the
technology to do that we don't have
the technology to do a whole lot of
experiments that he would like to make
but the answer from a first principles
uh perspective is there in potentia
it doesn't require your assumptions run
the experiment and the behavior of
nature will give you the answers
the answer is about how nature behaves
so if it behaves a lot
like an onion then it is like an onion
and the
the question is settled i agree with
fine when it comes when it comes however
to what nature
is not how it behaves but what nature is
experiment doesn't settle the question
it does inform the question
if you have a hypothesis about what
nature is and according to that
hypothesis nature can't behave in a
given way and then you run an experiment
and
lo and behold nature does behave in that
way then that hypothesis
is off the table but there is a whole
number of hypotheses
that are not contradicted by nature's
behavior so an experiment a scientific
experiment doesn't settle metaphysical
questions
it informs those questions you can be a
more educated metaphysician
by paying attention to science but
science alone cannot settle
a metaphysical question unless it's a it
settles it in a negative it can exclude
possibilities but it cannot settle it in
the positive by saying
this is the truth no scientific
experiment can settle the question
positively only by an elimination
because the answer
in the form of a behavior doesn't settle
the question of what
that which behaves is in and of itself
now what does this have to do with not
accepting three
worlds getting there getting there in
there sorry sorry it's a convoluted
answer but i'm getting there
so if you understand that science cannot
settle metaphysical questions
then what criteria do you have to judge
which metaphysical hypothesis is
superior
the criteria are different and they are
and i enumerate them to you
internal logical consistency
empirical adequacy in other words
empiricism cannot positively settle the
question
but your metaphysical theory cannot
contradict
observations otherwise it's just wrong
so internal logical consistency
empirical adequacy
coherence is important and coherence has
to do
not with the internal logical
consistency of your theory
but how it coheres with everything else
we do know
and there is this other great guiding
principle which is conceptual parsimony
now i will grant to you that there is
nothing etched in stone
saying that nature has to be the
simplest version of itself
it's not etched in stone it's a
subjective value
but i would argue to you that if we
ignore this value
we are off to the races we will be in a
mad house in no time
because you see everything
can have countless more complex
explanations
if you wake up in the morning and you
see footprints in your backyard
i mentioned two possible explanations
for that
one a burglar trying tried to invade
your house didn't succeed
went away and left the footprints behind
explanation a
explanation b aliens from the pleiades
came through a hyperspace
landed in your neighbor's backyard stole
your neighbor's shoes
jumped over the fence and went for a
straw in your backyard
then jumped back back put your
neighbor's shoes back where they were
boarded their spaceship and went back to
the pleiades
the second explanation explanation b
accounts
for the observations just as well as the
first
just as well as the first why do you
choose a instead of b
because b is more conceptually
parsimonious
it requires less assumptions you see
this sounds like a argument for the
functionalism of having a small amount
of assumptions but not as to the
ontological
correct correct i'll admit that yeah
but i admit to that while emphasizing
how important it is
if we don't hold to conceptual parsimony
as a value for identifying the best
metaphysical options
forget science science can those
questions are settled by experiment we
are talking
about being here about metaphysics if we
ignore conceptual parsimony
we have to embrace the flying spaghetti
monster
and i don't mean this metaphorically i
mean this literally
because the flying spaghetti monster
theory accounts for all facts
just as well as as a
quantum field theory and and and and
relativity
you can always explain all facts by
saying that
the invisible nudely appendages of the
flying spaghetti monster
is orchestrating everything the way it
is
so yes it's an epistemic and subjective
criterium criteria criteria criterium
admit to that there's nothing objective
etched in stoning nature saying that
nature has to be the simplest version of
itself
so admit to that but with one hand they
admit to that with
the other hand i highlight to you how
indispensable this subjective criteria
criterion is
because the the alternative is madness
it's it's complete nonsense
he's the flying spaghetti monster being
taken very seriously
bernardo i love you i feel like we're
out of oneness
i feel like your theory may be true
because i'm i'm here in tune with you
right now
but i don't see your theory as being
much more different than the flying
spaghetti monster
because you're saying i don't mean that
as insulting at all please please
i'm so i'll admit that i know so little
that
i wouldn't even identify as being
agnostic i'm so agnostic that i'm not
even agnostic
but i know very little too right right
right
okay so what so how is your theory much
different than someone saying
that well that's just the way it is
because god made it that way and why
can't one just say that
that seems like it's actually even more
simpler what's even more simpler by the
way solipsism so i'm wondering like why
don't you just choose that
i do have my own ideas as to why you
don't but we can talk about that after
i wrote about that look i am a
naturalist
a complete naturalist i think things
behave the way they behave because
nature is what it is and we can reduce
things like we can reduce the human
organism down to organs
and organs down to tissues and tissues
down to cells and cells to molecules and
molecules to atoms
and atoms to subatomic particles and
those
to quantum fields so i grant
all that i'm a naturalist i'm not saying
that
things happen the way they are simply
because they are what they are
this is an expression of those who
deny reductionism i don't deny
reductionism i am
an extreme reductionist i want to reduce
everything to one
right i'm an extreme form of a
reductionist in an extreme form of a
naturalist
because i say what is happening is
because nature is what it is and it's
all
it can all be reduced to that one thing
that nature is
the thing is whatever position you have
as a reductionist at the end you come to
something that is not
further reducible you cannot explain one
thing in terms of another forever
you have to come to at least one
you have to come to something that is
reducible at the end
but in terms of which you can explain
everything else
philosophers call this your reduction
set your reduction base
when you say reduction based that's the
same as math it's the axioms
yeah it's it's correlate with that yeah
the axioms are
the reduction base of a mathematical
theory yeah
um but but i mean that in an ontological
sense not in a modeling sense
so all reductionists who have to have a
reduction base with at least one element
because the alternative to that is
circularity and nobody
nobody's seriously proposing circularity
yeah okay we can talk about that
there are some people i'm sure you get
emails of some people saying somehow we
can bootstrap ourselves from nothing
now there are some people who say even
quantum fluctuations but that requires
you need at least potentials yes you
cannot pull something out of nothing
there has to be at least potentials so
they are defining existence in a
certainly different and more restrictive
way
but yeah okay i understand to go back to
the point
um every reductionist need a reduction
with at least one element
so why do i think my theory is more
parsimonious well let's
compare to the competition let's see
what else is on the table out there
if you are a naive materialist the
competition is a reduction base that
contains
every element in in the in the
menu of fundamental particles of of
uh our best model of
micro microscopic nature we have today
um
and there is a menu of several particles
several fermions
uh the the bosons there are several
particles
it's over a dozen so if you're a naive
materialist
that's your reduction base those things
exist because they just exist
and they have no relation to each other
and they are what they are simply
because
they are what they are that's it you end
there okay that
i submit to you that that's less
parsimonious than reducing everything to
one
natural consciousness now let's look at
the more sophisticated less naive
competition let's look at the quantum
field theorists
they reduce those particles to the
corresponding
fields so they different electrons
are not really separate they are not all
in your reduction base
they are just patterns of vibration of
one field for all electrons
okay that's a huge step forward now
instead of a reduction base with
gazillions of elements
now we have only a handful one field for
each
type of fundamental subatomic particle
but it is still several
several elements in your reduction base
so i'm more parsimonious than that so
is there more sophisticated competition
well there is there is the string
theorists
of the unified field uh quantum
theorists
or the loop quantum gravity folks right
or the m
theorists and they reduce those fields
and they try to reduce those fields to
one
but then they fail to explain
consciousness because the trick of a
reduction base is not only
that it has to be as small as possible
but you have to explain everything in
terms of it
that's the criterium you can have a
reduction base with only one arbitrary
element
by saying well i explain one thing with
this one arbitrary element but i failed
to explain everything else but
that that that's not fair that's not how
the game's played
so you have to put s few elements in
there but you still have to explain
everything else in terms of them
i submit to you that the m theorists and
unified quantum field theorists
they fail to do that unless they say
that their quantum fields
is just a model for consciousness
and then you can reduce everything to
that so my
claim to having them a parsimonious
theory of nature a philosophical one not
a scientific one
is based on the fact that i believe and
that
the case i have been putting forward for
years in a variety of books and articles
scientific and otherwise
technical and otherwise i believe i can
argue that i can reduce
everything to one field of consciousness
if you will
one instinctive natural consciousness
that underlies all reality
if i can do that then i think it's an
objective fact
that my theory is the most parsimonious
it may not be the right one
but of those on the table it's
definitely the most parsimonious
have you heard of ken wilbur i have
heard of him an integral theory and i
know nothing about it
okay so how about where do you disagree
with schopenhauer
i know he's you're you're standing on
the shoulders of him
and you grant him plenty of status but
i'm curious
given that you you know something i
don't like
about watching philosophers debate
this you're somewhat characteristic of
this as well is they'll reference
schopenhauer and then certain ancient
texts you don't do this all the time but
i i don't like that because
it's as if schopenhauer is interpretable
but it's not as if there's a consensus
on that and it's not as if there's a
consensus
as to what the ancient texts mean so
when people appeal to them i'm thinking
the ideas have to stand on their own now
you can always say it's
something funny about nietzsche is that
nietzsche
philosophized with the hammer famously
and when you read it it's like someone
with a megaphone
speaking from a one-way mirror and then
you can't speak back to them so what do
you mean when you said that there's no
such thing as facts
well then you're just left with well he
said there's no such thing as facts and
he said it so emphatically
okay let me interpret that's interesting
but you can't actually converse with
them
so either way that's just a little rant
when you talk about schopenhauer can you
compare and contrast you've studied
schopenhauer probably more than anyone
else that i know or maybe anyone else on
the planet
so where do you agree and disagree with
him on
can i comment just briefly on your
preface to the question
um i i i don't think it's fair to
compare nature to schroppenhauer in that
sense
because nietzsche although you can
discern his meanings to exclude at least
the most outrageous interpretations of
him
like the nazi interpretation of
nietzsche is outrageous
he said the contrary of what that
nietzsche was not a nationalist he was
an anti-nationalist he was the first
european he called himself the first
european
he didn't care about national boundaries
he cared about culture and he was very
critical of german culture
so his his co-opting by the nazis was
just
outrageous right one of the greatest
offenses in the history of philosophy
but he wrote in a nomic
way because his eyesight was so poor
he couldn't write real books his only
real complete book
was the birth of tragedy
which was the first everything else was
a collection of extended aphorisms
in the genealogy of morals he tried to
to write three or four
more complete essays but they are essays
even the genealogy of morals is not
really a complete book his only book was
the first
so he couldn't see he couldn't write
properly
so he couldn't really spend a lot of
time elaborating on his ideas
he had to make brief notes and he
published those notes in the form of
aphorisms
the gay science or because these words
have been co-opted today
the joyful wisdom his book is a
collection of aphorisms and so is a
human ultra human it's a collection of
aphorisms
so it's very difficult to say
what nietzsche really meant especially
because he changed his mind
during his life he was very fond of
schopenhauer at some point in the early
days then
he said chopin howard was completely
wrong and he blundered everything
he he actually writes that schopenhauer
blundered this just like he blundered
about anything else
he says that in his weird autobiography
ecce homo so it's very difficult to
pin down nietzsche's meaning because you
have to ask well
when was he writing if you're saying
that nietzsche thought this and when did
he think this was it in the early days
in the mid-career or in the late days
uh and even then it's difficult to pin
down his meaning schopenhauer on the
other hand was consistent
the second edition of the world uh as we
and
or the final edition in his lifetime of
the world as we own representation
i believe came in 1853 the first edition
was in 1818
and guess what he extended it but he
didn't change a word of the first
edition
he didn't change our word of what he
wrote
in his early 30s and late 20s when he
was in his late 60s
so the coherence of his message is not
comparable with
nietzsche because schopenhauer wrote the
same thing
over and over again in a multitude of
different ways
never really contradicting himself if
you have the eyes to read it
and not to misinterpret it so i think we
can pin down what you've been hearing
whether he's right or wrong now where do
i disagree with him
i am not a misogynist to begin with
he okay yeah he was a terrible
misogynist
a contemptible misogynist um
he was an optimist sorry he was an open
heart
that said the devil's laughter is what's
hurt after sex
he was not against sex uh no no just
that
that demonstrates the difference between
our base desires
and our intellect that right after
copulation
the devil's laughter is heard because
it's right then that you're like what am
i doing
why did i masturbate to that i don't
know why am i here
my study of schopenhauer is mostly
focused on his metaphysics and he had a
lot more to say just about
about just about everything else but i
focus on his metaphysics it could be i
don't i cannot know
okay in a sense i know less of
schopenhauer than i know of nietzsche
i certainly known less of schopenhauer
than i know of jung because the latter
two
uh young nietzsche i've read everything
they ever wrote
including uh the class that's
commendable
jung is difficult to read like extremely
extremely
dense and there's so much flowery
language it's ostentatious it takes
it it takes me maybe four times the
time that i was spending anything else
just to read him can i make a suggestion
for you
on the first read ignore the footnotes
do yourself this favor
when you're reading a book by young for
the first time don't
read the footnotes it will completely
break the flow of the book
to drive you nuts because he is
scholastic beyond belief
he's like a middle-aged scholastic
philosopher when it comes to footnotes
don't read them then after you finished
reading it
yeah after you read it once two eyes on
the third read
then you come back and then read the
footnotes but
don't do this just favorite yourself and
read the footnotes on the first read
uh it will make the work um impossible
it will
just get stuck in a more wrath of of
obscure references that is impossible
okay to manage
but uh about schopenhauer yeah
schopenhauer
philosophically i have a hard time
finding
a salient point of disagreement
i would say this i don't think he went
all the way he didn't
dot all the eyes and cross all the t's
he left some points
open for which he just hinted that or
suggested solutions for instance
he hinted that dissociation as the
mechanism
to explain why we have a personal will
while the will in fact is unitary
because it's not bound by space and time
by the principle of individuation as he
called it
in other words to separate one thing
from another according to schopenhauer
you need to say that they either occupy
different volumes of space
or they occupy the same volume of space
at different points in time if there is
no space time
within which you can tear things has to
be differentiation yeah
okay yeah then things are one and and he
said the and space and time is a is a
mode of cognition
it doesn't exist out there therefore the
will the world as it is in itself
out there can only be one because there
is no space time
for you to to have diversity yet yet he
admitted
that we are individual beings and
animals too
uh he says that automator we are not
because he said and now i will quote
word by word because the the subject
the eye that sees the world through us
is the same eye that sees the world
through every other animal so there is
unity
but there is a variety of perspectives
there is unity in essence but a variety
of perspectives
and he failed to account for how this
variety of
perspectives arose in the first place he
hinted at it by writing an entire
chapter about
cognitive associations and how without
the ability to cognitively associate one
thing with another
we would have no unity of mind he wrote
an entire chapter about that
but he failed to take the immediate next
step is
to say but it is the lack of cognitive
associations that explain the variety of
points of view
and that's what makes the unitary will
seem to be many
now he didn't take that bloody final
step
although he flirted with it he hinted at
it
how is that a step because it sounds
like what you're saying is well how is
there a difference when we're all from
the same
provenance from the same fountainhead
you have to explain the illusion of
separation
and then you're saying well you just
explain it by saying that we're
dissociated
you have to propose a mechanism that
allows you to reduce diversity to a
unity
because diversity diversity simply
happens as an appearance i can't read
your thoughts
i cannot help but experiencing
differentiation between me and you
because i don't know exactly what you're
thinking right now i don't know how you
feel about life and the world
so i have to account for this variety of
perspectives and this seeming
differentiation
even if it's not true differentiation in
the sense that at the fundamental
level there is no differentiation at all
you have to account for how at least the
appearance
of differentiation arises and
schupenhauer flirted with a way to
account for that
but didn't go all the way so i so
instead of disagreeing with him i could
point out
the few places where i think i'm
prepared to go beyond
to go further than he did but of course
it's much easier for me to do that today
because i have
an entire scientific
dictionary of terms whose meaning people
already understand
i can talk about dissociation today
because i know there's a whole branch of
science called psychiatry that studied
this phenomenon
accounted for it described it we know
a lot about it so i can use one word and
say dissociation and i account for it no
sure
i didn't have any of that so admittedly
if i had lived in his time with the
ideas that i have today
i would have had an unfathomably bigger
challenge than he had
and i'm very open about this i think i
would have done a much much
much worse job than he did in his time
so i see himself as superior to me in
almost every way
but yeah with the benefits of living in
a much more advanced
scientific culture today being able to
use terms and leverage knowledge that is
available to everyone today and was not
available at his time
then i dare say we can go beyond what he
did he went beyond count and i think
today we can go beyond him
this gets to the heart of what it means
to be one oneness
and also you can help me out here
sometimes when i speak about the people
who
think that we all belong to one vellum
we're just one consciousness and we're
just excitations of so and so
i call them the new age spiritual types
but i i don't mean that derogatorily
i don't mean that in any defamatory
manner i don't i just don't know how
else to
refer to them because not all of them
say comfortable no then sometimes i mean
it's derogatory
yeah so do you mind giving me a word
that i can use such that
those people won't roll their eyes when
i refer to them because i
i'm not even saying that i'm not one of
them like i i'm i'm probably closer to
them than they think
but i don't want to demean them yeah
integrate them
let's start this by making some obvious
admissions
things that we cannot help but admit
there
is a lot of new age [ __ ] there's a
lot of new age
nonsense i wouldn't go as far as to say
that the whole new age movement is
[ __ ]
that is extremely implausible that's not
how things happen
but a lot of the noisy visible part of
the new
age is flagrant nonsense
is flagrant gullible [ __ ]
and i don't hold my tongue back for that
and i regret
that the idea of one consciousness has
is now in in the popular mind so
associated with that kind of
yes gullible new age spiritual blah blah
blah i don't want to use the term
woo-woo because it's
right exactly what would be two examples
of
the new age types yeah now now you put
me in and i'll tell you why i say this
because
because to me i my mind is so it's
it's trying to find what's true in even
what sounds
insensitive that if they say well
we can remote view and we can have
psychic phenomena and ufos exist
and so on what i know that's not
necessarily new age but whatever it may
be i'm always thinking
well how is that true in some way okay
first of all how is it false it's
immediate to both you and i how that
could be false that's our natural
predilection but then i'm thinking well
how is it true and then i
i find that it's true in ways that are
revealing of such depth
that for me to dismiss them outright
would be for me to be like sabine
haasenfelder
who i admire and i've had on this
channel i do too
but she has good things to say yeah but
she is much like almost any materialist
that says
well if you can't define it then don't
bother with it it's
if it sounds on the surface
superficially cosmetically to be foolish
then it
it's not worth your time go shut up and
calculate
so she has that mindset whereas i have
the mindset of of
there's there's gold in the in the
rubble and i'll faucet i'll search
around
i have the same mindset great great
great great so what's so
given that what are give one example of
what the new age people take
i'm not going to zoom in on a specific
person although i could
i'll say this most of it i think is
nonsensical
um the core of it the essence of it
probably is not um i don't want to name
authors but i i can give you sort of
examples and if you can match examples
to authors then it's your problem you
are doing this not me i don't care
too much about that i'm more interested
in ideas ideas that
the stuff that was so visible before
2012
um all that 2012 phenomenon about
i have difficulties paraphrasing it
because
it was so nonsensical to have difficult
even paraphrasing it although i remember
yeah at the end of the world stuff but
there wasn't there was intricate sorry
intricate
fear is being proposed like there are
waves of a particular frequency coming
from the center of the galaxy
and they enter your heart and the kind
of
or there are aliens in the pleiades that
are at war and
i associate that so much with the new
age but
there are aliens who were who are at war
with a cabal
of human beings and these words
happening in the space above our heads
right now as we go busy ourselves with
banal
work and daily life i mean all this kind
of
ice cream [ __ ] toxic nonsense
made to to create
fictional images and make money that
stuff that is exploitative outright
exploitative
and i could not i'm i'm revealing myself
more now to you than i have ever done in
a in a
in an interview my level of
contempt for the [ __ ]
that many of my critics feel contempt
for
runs above the contempt my critics have
above those things um well that lends
credence more credence to you
i don't think so because it's a
subjective thing it's an emotional thing
it's not impartial what i mean to say is
that
if you find a certain set of ideas to be
ridiculous that people associate you
with but yet you believe
some overlap of it not all of it then
that means that
you're not driven there by pure want or
desire yeah but the reason i have
contempt for them is not because i am
associated with them i don't care too
much about that i
have my message to say and i say my
message and if you want to
associate me with something i didn't say
well that's your problem it's not my
problem
i don't have a problem with that even if
i didn't play the role i'm playing now
an author promoting a certain
metaphysical view suppose i was
just suppose i were still just
uh an executive in high tech in high
technology or an engineer
i would still have contempt i have such
a natural
spontaneous contempt for some of that
[ __ ]
that it goes beyond what uh what you
could say well this is
reasonable and thought through now it's
just a visceral reaction
that that i have sometimes um but it's
not to the to all of the new age i mean
the deepak for instance is often
associated with a new age i
i maybe that was the case in the 80s i
don't know because i i didn't look but
the deepak i have known
for eight years
now i i have no association between him
and new age [ __ ] because everything
he says i find
eminently reasonable and and and
important
uh but there is stuff in the new age now
especially when it comes to the pleiades
and and cabals that oh
okay bernardo let me reveal myself then
to you a little bit about deepak
so here's what i see with deepak not
about his ideas but more about
his personality what i see when he
interviews some of the intellectuals
like stewart hammer off or even yourself
i watched that interview
i see someone who is not
like please i don't mean this in a
negative way i don't see someone who is
searching for the truth no matter how it
is i see someone as
already accepting that consciousness is
one and that the ancient
indian text that he has grew up with
grown up with
is correct in some way shape or form and
and that's fine because it could be
like who knows right christianity could
be correct judaism could be correct
islam could be correct whatever whatever
it may be
but i see him as when he's interviewing
scientists
he's looking because he's been so hurt i
think i see someone
who's been so hurt by the accusations
from the 90s or early 2000s of being
unscientific and using wu-wu
that he now when he sees a scientist
that agrees with him
five percent in some interpretation he's
like can you can you elaborate on that
five percent
oh okay and so when when people accuse
me of saying that uh that that
that i'm saying unscientific bs what do
you say to that
he'll ask that question plenty and i see
it as
a little boy who's just been so hurt
that he wants the validation from the
scientific community
and so he's willing to interpret
what the scientist is saying in order to
validate what he already believes in and
or
and in order to shove it in the face of
his critics that's what i see now that's
almost like the union in me or the
freudian that's looking for the
unconscious motivations
yeah but i i can't help but see that i
also see this a bit in
almost anyone who has a world view that
they're they ardently defend
now there's great they should i'm an
apologist for apollo for apologists in
general because apologist means to
defend what you believe in with
justifications
and i think that you should if you
believe in something if you're an
intellectual you should justify it
but then there's some people who justify
it like let's say
sam harris or deepak or
it runs the gamut it's more than just
an intellectual justification it seems
more like defensiveness and it
ended and then i wonder how much of what
they believe is because they've
dispassionately took an assessment of
the data and come to the conclusion
rather than they have some predilection
or some predisposition much like you
said which is so interesting about
materialism
sam harris would say well look the way
that you can believe what i'm saying is
that it goes against my own interests
because
i would love to believe that
christianity was correct
so then if someone says that and they
don't believe it then you then that
lends a bit more credence but then at
the same time sam herrera says i don't
want to believe in a god that kills
people
so arbitrarily and also heaven
comes with hell in some interpretations
right and you said that about
materialism is that
this is extremely interesting in
materialism
there is comfort as much as the
atheist would say that there is no
comfort there's more comfort in
traditional religion
yet i don't agree with that because i am
such a rationalist
well there's comfort in knowing that
your life is going to end oh how's their
comfort in knowing my life is going to
end
because you don't know what is at the
other side you don't know if agony
awaits you infinitely infinite torment
or infinite pleasure you don't know
and so there is comfort in the certainty
that maybe this is it
that's so interesting i never heard it
posed that way before it
it's the elephant in the room and it's
such an enormous elephant
elephant that people don't see it they
only see a patch of skin in front of
them
because the elephant is giant
let's let's just put it this way and i'm
sure everybody will agree with this
because it's objectively the case the
single
greatest fear human beings have
always had of any generation before the
19th century the single
greatest greatest fear in the lives of
every human being
has been the experiential state
after bodily death the fear of what
comes after
is what have kept people in line and
turned the christian church into a
political institution of tremendous
power
to the point that it still has a country
of its own the vatican
it was the leveraging and the use of
that
fear of what will happen to you after
you die will you go to hell
or will you go to heaven would there be
monsters
that has been the greatest single fear
in the
history of humanity it has allowed
peoples to be controlled throughout
history
and it is the one thing that materialism
has taken
off the table it has nutrient
the greatest fear in the history of
humankind
it's off the table it's no longer
credible you do not need to worry about
that
this is a social historical
fact and a psychological fact
do you fear death and then now i do
right in this moment you do or do you
mean generally speaking i do look i am
as intellectually convinced as one can
possibly be
that my core subjectivity is
in your which is the same in you which
is the same in my cat and everywhere
is the one entity in the reduction base
in in other words all reality unfolds in
it
it's it's the one thing that exists and
therefore it has nowhere to go
and it's never going to end it's where
beginnings and sorry what has no way
no what what is the core subjectivity in
me is going nowhere
because everything that happens happens
in it
and it's not only my course objectivity
the course objectivity in me is the same
course objectivity in you
it's the one eye of the world that looks
out from every creature as schopenhauer
put it
so i'm as intellectually convinced as
one can be
that my subjectivity survives bodily
death and probably witnesses
the entire process now what is the best
and safe analog to death we have today
what's the
the one thing we can do that comes the
closest to death
physiologically and and still can be
done safely
let's hide those psychedelics the
psychedelics the way they operate is by
significantly reducing brain activity
not sorry not anesthesia
anesthesia is a dissociative it
increases noise levels in your brain
it doesn't necessarily reduce brain
activity
and there are there is a strong
scientific argument to be made that you
are not unconscious during anesthesia
uh you are just incoherent so you you
cannot focus
on any particular experience no no no it
means that you do not suffer
there is too much incoherence in brain
signals to form
the coherent experience of a profound
pain
it can't happen because the signal is
dispersed to your conscious self but
what if there are other parts of you
that are feeling it that can remember
much like when you have childhood trauma
and then you dissociate
there is a part of you that's filling
everything that can possibly be felt has
ever been felt and whatever be felt
right if it's almost unconsciousness
there is a part of you correct
so the best model we have is
psychedelics actually not
not uh anesthesia because psychedelics
under neuroimaging
they have been proven every psychedelic
studied so far since 2012 until now
has have this consistent behavior brain
activity significantly reduces
especially in the default mode network
the part of your brain that has to do
with your individual sense of self
the part of your brain the process in
your brain that says
i am curt or i am uh bernardo
the re that part of brain activities is
smashed your brain goes to sleep in that
regard and and and i know from
experience
that um the experience that is
correlated with that
which is called ego dissolution
is an incredibly difficult
experience to undergo it's when you're
constantly dying and you're never dead
it's that feeling that of losing
everything that you are
or what have you experienced yeah i have
experienced
uh ego dissolution under high dose
psychedelics more than once
does it get easier
in a certain way yes in a certain way no
the feelings are never less powerful so
in that sense it does not
get easier the feelings are just as
intense i've experienced something
akin to eco death where it's like i'm in
a oneness
i'm in a void but it wasn't black it was
white but i felt like
almost like the tentacles of an octopus
and then you go back to the head
and i couldn't explain it any other way
and everything made sense
you get this profound realization that
all the laws of physics are the way
because of so-and-so but then you forget
so and so and then even if you do
remember it days later you're like that
doesn't make sense
discard it the the tentacles are the
dissociative pathways and you are
undergoing a reduction in dissociation
and your mind presents itself to you in
a pictorial manner
and then you're going back from the
tentacles to the head to the godhead
from the dissociated tentacles it makes
all sense of the world
but look nobody has ever physically died
from psychedelic ingestion it's not
physically possible people die of the
stupidity they do
while under the influence but your ego
does die
you as a body don't but your ego your
sense of an
individual agency of being an individual
agent
that sense is smashed to smithereens
and it feels as death because it smashes
that
which you think you are and it feels
horrible
so doing it repeatedly it feels as
horrible but there is one silver lining
and that is
you know what's happening and there's a
little voice in the back of your head
saying
just hang on tight this will pass and
there is bliss
on the other side and there is because
when your sense of individual self
dissolves
you are the universe and that such
it's the greatest joy one can imagine
it's a profound sense of identification
with the true
reality and everything else until that
point was an illusion
and it's a reality of total acceptance
total integration
um because you are that which needs to
accept
so it completes an unconditional
acceptance
uh but before that heaven there is the
hell
of ego dissociation parting with that
what did i say ego dissociation it meant
ego dissolution
which corresponds to a reduction in
dissociation because the ego is the
dissociative process
so when the ego dissolves it's the
dissociation that is dissolving
a reuniting a reintegration which which
is blissful
except that in that in-between stage it
feels like you're being
annihilated your soul is being
annihilated
and and it's the worst experience that i
think
that i have ever had no worse than that
is the re-entries when you are in the
bliss and then you come back to the ego
that's worse
um but ego dissolution is terrible and
uh
and my own theory informed me that
physical death real death permanent
death when you die and you're dead
um that's the ultimate ego dissolution
so i know bliss is coming and i will
know blizzcon
and i'm thankful to psyched alex for
that for not telling me this only
conceptually but
showing me what it is so being convinced
to the bone that ultimately
bliss is coming but i shiver
by thinking of what ultimate ego
dissolution might feel like
and i dread it and i fear it
profoundly and i didn't fear it when i
was a sort of
unthinking materialist by default
because
there's literally nothing to fear when
you're you're dead
there is nobody there to feel bad it
takes such strength to admit that
because most people are the opposite
where they'll say
i was fearful of death when i was a
materialist then i died with ego
dissolution
that's right dissolution and then i came
back and i realized okay well death is
just another state
that is not much different than this and
it's blissful and so on
well you know if what you told me about
samara is saying that you can trust what
he says
because it goes against what he wishes
if that's true i mean that's nonsensical
even if it's true that he
that he thinks that i mean it's the
ultimate logical fallacy
uh uh this is not a logical argument for
the validity of your position to say
well i fear it so yes i could apply that
to myself and you're you're doing me the
favor of doing that you're being very
kind to me
but to be very honest kurt i don't think
this means anything it has no
logical force whether i like the
conclusion or not
it has no bearing on the force of my
argument for that conclusion
people should look at my argument does
my argument hold water
so if some harris thinks i should trust
what he says because it goes against
what
against what he wishes i would say
[ __ ] i don't give a
damn what you wish or don't wish tell me
your argument i would judge your
argument
not how you feel about it no i agree i
agree so the fact that i feel bad
about the idealist sense of death that
consciousness persists and we want to go
you go the solution i do fear that and
i'm saying that to you not because i'm
trying to promote myself on the other
precisely the contrary but i don't think
you or anybody should construe this as
something that helps the force of my
argument it
shouldn't my argument hopefully is
objective how i
feel about its implications should be
irrelevant it is relevant to me
when people go in states and they say
that what i experienced was real it was
more real than this
you talked about this a few times then
we dismissed that reality
should we be now there are good reasons
to dismiss it because
i imagine well this is just a
speculation on my part
though it's though there's some basis to
it i think
professor john verviki said that the
sense of realness can be induced
there's a cortical loop inside your
brain and the faster it goes there's a
certain
cortical loop i don't recall which one
the faster it is the more you feel like
that's real whatever it is
so then you could say well psychedelic
spin that wheel quicker so you feel as
if it's real but it's not necessarily
yeah yeah yeah
so then how do we okay yeah my
relationship with
psychedelic noses is probably the
reverse of what most
psychonauts would report i'm not really
a psychonaut i did that as a sort of a
part of a research effort it's not
something that i was exultant about
doing
it's you know if i'm talking if i'm
going to talk about consciousness i
better know what i'm talking about
so i felt obliged to do that and it has
been contributed a lot
um to my development as a person and so
i'm thankful to psychedelics for that
even though i think it's not for
everyone
and should be done with extreme care um
when it's not legal
um my sense of psychedelic knows this is
the following there is
no doubt that when you are
deep within a trip when you pass those
initial stages which are hallucinatory
in nature but
when you pass through that when you
break through really to the other side
there is no doubting that that
feeling that this is ultra real
this is a lot more real than where i was
coming from i was completely deluded i
was in some kind of trance
and now i see what's really real so that
experience
exists there's no doubt about that can
you explain it away
no doubt about that either whether the
explanations are
true or not i reserve judgment but can
you in principle explain that sense of
reality away
in the way you suggested like something
spinning some mental process spinning
faster in your brain
possibly is that what is relevant about
this
i would say no it's completely relevant
let me tell you
what is relevant about that sense of
realness
it's stronger than the sense of realness
you have now
so if you can explain that away on the
same basis
you explain you can explain this away
right now so the message of the
psychedelic experience from me
is not that that is real and this is an
illusion
the message is that this is an illusion
do you see what i mean if you think
flip flip it around turn it the other
way around the message is not that's
real
the message is this is not real in the
way we
think it is real this too
is a mental configuration it's something
that mind is doing
so if mind can do something that makes
you have that sense of
ultra reality in a psychedelic state and
you explain that a way by saying it's
just mind
please be consistent with yourself and
do the same here
if your sense of reality now is less
real than that
please tell yourself inform yourself
this too is a trick of mine
there that is the important thing
let's talk about the malleability of
reality how much we can control it
because in a dream
or even in a psychedelic state where it
seems like what we're experiencing is
entirely real
now that's false when it comes to dreams
i don't recall
a dream where i felt like it was more
real than reality
but either way in a dream you can have a
loose dream you can control
that doesn't seem to apply here but yet
i hear many mystics and so on say that
this is a dream we need to wake up and
that's what enlightenment is or nirvana
and so on
so what i'm curious about is
it seems fair it seems evident to people
like me and you
that we can control our environment
around us with will
so that is with our thoughts now it's
not infinite
because i cannot grow a new arm from my
chest like a mortal kombat character
but but then that means that there are
limitations now what i'm wondering is
what are those limitations are those
limitations true
can one overcome virtually any
limitation with
sheer will what does that look like
i don't think so and i think there is a
very abundant evidence to the contrary
the essence of your question is can the
ego control everything can the ego
control the rest of mind
dissociated and not dissociated aspects
of it
i would say it's very fairly evident
that it cannot
look we can't control our dreams
most dreams even when you're having a
lucid dream often you can't control it i
have had
many lucid dreams when i was younger
of a dog running after me
and i knew it was a lucid dream and i
was like oh man i just need to wake up
wake up wake up and i couldn't wake up
and i couldn't stop the dog even though
i knew it was a lucid dream
kurt we can't control our thoughts you
don't know where your next thought is
coming from
you can't control your fears your
emotions you can't control your desires
you can act on them but you can't choose
what you desire
now you can go after what you desire but
you can't choose that otherwise we would
all be choosing to desire
to desire exactly that which we have
you can't control our fantasies our
imagination
a schizophrenic a person who for me is
just
a a human being with a different
different settings but not different
from
from me or you cannot control his quote
hallucinations
um we can't control our minds let alone
the world
we have very very little control of our
own minds if you think of it
this idea that the difference between
reality and dream
is that we can control a dream and you
can't control reality it's
based it's quite a widespread intuition
but
it's surprising how quickly it melts
away if you just give it
some thought um we can't control the
dreams just like we can't control
reality
we can't control even the thoughts we
have in this reality
we can't control our opinions our
choices
seem to be limited to practical
practicalities like
i seem to be able to choose my mortgage
package i seem to be able to choose
which car would drive
can i choose my partner no i can't even
choose my partner i don't i don't choose
who i fall in love with
yeah yeah i i'm assuming that we're
having a bit of a conflict with what it
means to be i
what is the i choosing because that's
the exactly you go you go
it's because the eye we think is
choosing doesn't even exist
it's a dissociative condition it's not
real
it's an appearance a natural appearance
a natural process
registered by us as something that seems
to be real but it's not
it's reducible it's explainable in terms
of a broader mind
so the i that chooses is not even there
how can it possibly choose
of course it's not choosing doesn't
exist look
did i choose to write the books i wrote
no i didn't did they choose to
to be working for essentia foundation
today i didn't
oh what did i choose to be an engineer
essentia foundation
it's a foundation dedicated to promoting
idealism i didn't choose that
and i i have only achieved peace in my
life
by how to say
by accepting that that which i
ordinarily think as i
is not choosing anything in my life and
there is freedom
and liberation in that acceptance
because there
there is a sense in which you let
responsibility go
that you are riding a wave and you're
not choosing where the wave is going
your only choice is do i swim against it
or do i go with it and if you go with it
you have a higher you have an easier
time
that's about it uh but you're not going
to change the direction in which you're
going because the wave overpowers you in
union terminology
what's choosing is the collective
unconscious it's what we call the
unconscious it's not unconscious at all
what the young mentor was is the self
the known self-reflective parts of mind
the parts of mind that
are not accessible through explicit
introspection but it's consciousness it
is conscious
and young used the word psychic for it
it is
psychic it's psychic in nature meaning
it's experiential
but it's not accessible through explicit
introspection so
it is that which is choosing it is the
connective unconscious
it is the last dissociated parts of our
minds or the completely known
dissociated
mind at large that's the natural wave
remember i am a naturalist
and nature is a big wave it's going
somewhere we can choose to swim with it
or swim against it you can choose to be
tools of it
or to rebel against it and lose you're
guaranteed to lose
you're super interesting super
interesting so you're saying that nature
is this huge force and it generally
controls you
way more than you think you are an
aspect of it so you're not even separate
from it
so even to say it controls you is
already a categorical mistake
you're not distinct from it but you just
have a
hallucinated narrative about what you
are
in other words nature has a hallucinated
narrative about what it is
and it goes in conflict against itself
because of it
choices are instinctive there is
something instinctive that runs through
you
and is calling the shots all the
important shots
the problem is we think it is us
choosing it so we rebel against it or we
regret
against choices and suffering pours out
uh from that dynamics which is also
natural dynamics
it's nature fooling itself it's all
natural so the choice to swim
with the current rather than against it
is that choice
yours or is that choice ultimately
another current in which case
nature can offer less resistance against
itself let's put it that way if i
because you see it's impossible to use
terms in a completely unambiguous way
because the terms like i or doing
or resisting or nature that they have
already a social meaning
so if i try to be completely accurate i
will contradict that social meaning and
nobody will understand what i'm trying
to say so i have to be ambiguous
and seemingly contradictory per force if
i am to use language
i don't think bernardo castro exists as
a true
separate agency bernardo castro
is a ripple or a metaphor i prefer a
whirlpool
uh in in in the in the ocean of nature
it's a process it's a doing it's not a
thing
it's a cast trooping not a castro yeah
is that your intellectual mindset
is that your intellectual mind saying
that i don't believe bernard or castro
exist
that's my that's my intellect saying
okay but but you cannot feel that in the
moment but you then you're like
that's actually correct so let me tell
you that so
sorry what's what's then you suffer look
a conceptual understanding
is not transformative you need it to
open the doors to another type of
understanding because the intellect is
the bouncer of the heart
so felt understanding doesn't come
through if your intellect is saying
that's not plausible or that is
impossible in principle
so you need an intellectual discourse in
order to allow your intellect to relax
and give yourself permission to have a
different kind of understanding but if
you don't intellectually grant yourself
permission to do that
you're screwed so that's that's my fight
i'm trying to give
people i'm trying to help people give
themselves intellectual
permission to contemplate other things
than what
rationalist materialism would would
accept
consider acceptable or not but
ultimately this
is direct embodied experience that is
transformative
and i'm keeming aware of that um do you
have any free will
i don't think bernardo castro really
exists how can it have free will
if it's not there if free will is
bernardo castro can choose against
nature
because when another castro is separate
from nature then of course not
there isn't the entity there to have
free will
so even the question already presupposes
too much
so this is the difference between the
east and the west broadly speaking no
that the east seems to say well
suffering comes from your desires so
here's one solution
get rid of desire get rid of will but
then the west poses the other solution
which is
find something triumphant that can
justify the sorrow
so what do you say to that is that of a
correct characterization of the east
versus
i think it's fair i thought you were
going to say find something to realize
your desires on
that we know is a faulty uh recipe uh
the richest people in the world
also you know overdose in medication get
drunk and commit suicide
because every time you achieve a desire
it disappears it's like a ghost
so you have to go for the next but once
you play that 10 times you realize that
it's you're not going to get anywhere
and then you kill yourself
but what you said well you are you are
going to suffer find
meaning instead that that is the west
that characterizes the west and i don't
say that in a judgmental form because
that's what characterizes me
i am i mean i have profound admiration
for the east
um more than admiration even
but i have made peace with the fact that
i am a western
in mind and i will always be western um
and and yes as a westerner i find
consolation in meaning
knowing that desires cannot be fulfilled
knowing that
suffering is integral to life it's the
thing that keeps you awake with your
eyes on the ball
it's the thing that allows us to fulfill
whatever
tila's nature might be which might be
operating through us
if we never suffer we would just become
epicureans we will just
enjoy life and never think about the big
questions and nature will realize
no impetus no no go will not follow any
telos
if we are like that so suffering is
necessary it's a
dreadful but an indispensable tool
and the way out for me is to find
meaning and in that i am a westerner and
will always be
how much of a solution as to how you
should guide your life is to be
personalized rather than
adopted broadly from one tradition
versus the other
and i'll explain what i mean when you i
have to scroll down here because that's
distracting me i have it
also playing here and the chat is here
and sometimes it flashes
and it's i have a distracted
distracted mind okay so
i see people who are let's say the new
age spiritual types but even the
westerners who
are adamant about christianity or
whatever it may be saying no
this is what you should think my view
and i'm wondering well
well is this one pill or is it meant to
be personalized like a microbiome
so the west would say to the east what
you're doing is
you're not placing enough importance on
action and you're abnegating your own
individual importance and the east would
say to the west
yeah you're obstinate you're pig-headed
and you're refractory you're unwilling
to
give up your own ego and that's what you
should do so those are two different
solutions
now should we adopt one of them is it a
mix
is one ultimately correct now i think
you're suggesting one the eastern one is
actually the one that's
ultimately true in the sense that it
corresponds to what the facts are
but as for how we should live our life
is that a one size fits all or is it a
mix of both or is there even a third
solution we should pull from
i think the answer is always very
personal i can give you the answer
that i have for myself my answer my
truth in this regard and
i don't i don't think for a moment that
this particular thing
is an absolute truth um i
i think met physically the east has
gotten it right
and it keeps popping back up even in the
west and eventually we have to confront
the reality of what people in the
hindus valley centuries before our
soccer
centuries before alexander the great
[Music]
came into the neighborhood they already
knew
so that comes from the hindus valley
three three and a half thousand years
ago and i think
they got it they nailed it okay um
where i wouldn't go with the east and
that's my personal answer
where i am a western to the bone
is that although i am convinced that
personal agency our personal sense of
self
is an illusion i do think it's an
illusion with a role to play
nature has done this all right so how
did this come about
is there why is there an instinctive why
i'm sure it's not a premeditated
plan like the christian god um
but we've come to this and everything in
nature seems to be pushing
in that direction you know evolution by
natural selection
that has to be an environment conducive
to that the whole of nature seems to be
pushing that direction of
self-reflective seemingly personal
conscious agents
i wouldn't dismiss that as some kind of
cosmic error
that we need to grow out of i think we
need to understand
what is probably ultimately truth but
with that
the truth but without dismissing the
kind of experience that is made possible
through the illusion of individual
agency look it's through the association
that we can contemplate the universe
from a side that's not available to god
if i'm
allowed to use this word in a
metaphorical sense it is by being
dissociated that we can look at god from
the other side
in a self-reflective manner because
self-reflection is the product of
evolution by natural selection
we've paid a very dear price over three
and a half billion years of evolution on
this planet
to develop the ability to say i am a
thinking
entity nature has invested a lot in this
bloody affair
illusory as it may be a lot has gone
into this
so i am not dismissive of it i am with
the young on this
i am not for dismantling the images
i am not for meditating ourselves out of
existence
and becoming into some
mental space in which nothing really
happens becoming completely disengaged
from the world
from the others i'm not for that i think
this is all an illusion
but i think it's an illusion worthwhile
to play along with
but just keeping in mind at all times
that it is an illusion don't get
completely taken in
when you're playing the game but by all
means do play the game nature has
invested a bloody
lot in this we have to have
faith faith
that there is a point
because we have been born we are in this
extraordinarily strange condition of
being alive
if there is no point to it and then soon
enough you'll be dead then you
have nothing to lose anyway you never
had anything to lose from the get go
but in in the off chance that there is
an instinctive point to this that this
is
pushing towards something some desperate
need instinctual need for for
self-knowledge operating through
us into which nature is investing
unfathomable amounts of suffering
if there is enough chance that this may
be the case
i think it's our moral duty
to play the game not get taken in by it
but to play the game and explore the
world from this perspective
experience your suffering contemplate it
ponder about it
no we are in this situation not forever
soon enough we will not be
so take something out of it in the off
chance that there is something to be
taken out of it so in that sense i'm not
eastern
at all i think they got it right
metaphysically
but their moral truth is not my moral
truth
um i am for playing the game and you see
that in what i'm doing
look at me i'm playing the game am i
choosing to do this no i'm just not
resisting it
i'm giving i'm letting whatever wants to
come through the world through me
to come unopposed and it took me over
10 years of holding this philosophical
position i hold today
for this to become something that really
comes out of my bones as opposed to an
intellectual conceptual
thought so today and i i
can't tell you how much relief i feel in
being able to say this
with the hand of my heart and in all
honesty
today not last year not the year before
that not the 10 years before that
i live my philosophy
i embodied and i feel an amount of peace
today that one year ago
would have been unthinkable and what
brought me to this was
suffering
two years ago i almost killed myself
twice because of a health condition that
is incurable but will never kill me just
make me suffer beyond belief
i have a particularly hard form of
tinnitus people say ringing in the ears
but in my case it sounds like a
dentist's drill
about one meter distance one on each
side
and it's constant right now day and
night it's the last thing and right now
of course especially when i put
a headset on and i block environment
sounds then i lose
auditive depth and then i hear it
constantly it's the last thing i hear
when i fall asleep it's the first thing
i experience when i wake up
and when this really got worse i have it
i have had it for eight years or nine
but when it really got worse beginning
of 2019
um two eyes for half an hour
i the the the idea of killing myself was
not abstract at all it was something
very
very real very you know concrete in
front of me a very serious possibility
that
i was considering now
in ways that i for reasons that i cannot
explain
this suffering has brought me to the
state of peace i am in now
so for the first time my philosophy it
has always been
not abstract for me i have always been a
philosopher in the
classical sense in the sense that
philosophy is not a job for me
it's my guidance it's my guide to life
yeah so it has always been like that to
me but embodying my philosophy
is very recent and it it's with an
unending amount of joy that i'm
able to say that to you with a hand in
my heart in all honesty
i have surrendered uh my personal self
and life has become fantastic
meaningful pleasant of course it will
not last forever at some point i'll get
sick i will lose someone i love as it
has happened before
and it will be a whole bloody nightmare
again but look i am in peace right now
i'll take it
i don't know how long it will last but
i'll take it with gratitude
and it just makes my philosophy come to
life in me
uh and increases my commitment to it my
commitment my
sub course commitment to it not the
commitment commitment of bernardo castro
bernardo castro never wanted to do this
never wanted to write books
never wanted to leave the corporate
world never wanted to become a
more or less known philosopher bernardo
castro wanted to be a business executive
and i almost actually got to that and
then gave it up
sold at ibm yeah bernardo kassoup had
other plans about the ideal partner
my partner today my girlfriend today is
the choice of
the unconscious it's the true choice
it's the person that
needs to be in my life it's the person
nature wanted me to be with
in the sense that she and i are nature
um
and it was very different before it's
totally different way of relating
to each other to yourself to the world
um
very peaceful and everything happens
naturally
effortlessly giving an interview to you
i've been speaking for three hours and
15 minutes more actually because i
started recording
later i'm cognizant of your time and i
apologize it is floating
it's flowing effortlessly but that's
what i'm trying to say it flows
effortlessly
my books flow not effortlessly now i
would confess that
giving birth to a book is like giving
birth it's painful it wakes me up at
three in the morning and puts me in
front of this computer at three in the
morning even even if i have to wake up
at seven go to work the next day
um every book
it's like a costume so why do you
responsibility because
it's like a ball of hot iron that comes
up your esophagus
and you need to spit it out and the only
way to spit it out is to finish it
and and now now it's easier because
i don't resist it if that's what's going
to come tomorrow
then that's what's going to be and so
let it be
so there is freedom in what um
philosophers of ode would say the
slavery to the diamond
and the diamond is that superior force
that forces you to do
things in life as a philosopher oh damon
okay
aristotle had a depends on the spelling
aristotle had a daemon who told him what
not to do there are other flaws
socrates sorry and there are other
philosophers that have a demon
that tell them what to do um
so uh surrendering to slavery
towards my demon has been the ultimate
freedom
um so the freedom is not the ego winning
over
stealing the god from the fire stealing
the fire from the gods
and making the universe what it wants to
be that's impossible
because the ego doesn't even exist it's
a psychological
configuration it's a psychological
phenomenon in the
in the in the pejorative sense of the
meaning
meaning it's not really there it's just
something your mind is making up
that's what it is so how can it control
the world
it's not really there to begin with how
can something that doesn't exist
control what does exist so freedom for
me has not been achieved through the
mastery of control although
i thought i had mastered control by the
time i was 34
i was the youngest as i think i was the
youngest executive in my company
which is one of the top 50 companies in
europe it's not it was not as
it is not a small company
congratulations i'm not going to name
the company but a very very very large
and important company if that company
ceased to exist tomorrow
you would have no new phones computers
or ipads for at least five years
probably ten
so i had that illusion when i was
thirty-four
now i control life now i have money i
have a beautiful house i have a
beautiful wife a great job i have power
you had a wife before you were married i
had a wife before i had
my current partner yeah and my my
ex-wife is still a very close friend
uh we are not enemies at all on the
contrary but we're not married anymore
um and and then it's like instantly
after i got that promotion
and bought the house in which i lived
today which for dutch standard this is
wonderful large expensive house
and that i thought okay uh now i arrived
now now i have control i have the house
i have the wife i have the money i have
the position the power i have everything
and then it's amazing how life
immediately
cuts your [ __ ] short right um
through illness um i thought
well my wife then and i uh
discovered a a mass in her breast
and it took two weeks for the doctors to
confirm that it was benign it was
nothing to worry about but during those
two weeks
we lived with the reality that it was
probably cancer
and that was nature telling me you think
you're in control just because you have
a high position a beautiful house and
money in the bank let me show you what
control is i would take from you what
you care
most about or at least i will have you
think
that i would take from you what you care
most about and at the end of the day it
was not cancer she's alive and healthy
today
but the message the message was not was
not
lost on me we are never
ever in control we don't even exist
let alone be in control you are never in
control
you are like a mayfly you are an
ephemeral little dwing of
nature that will stop being done in no
time
before you even think boom it's over
thank you
and you are you have absolutely no
control buddy and if you think you have
you're in for a lot of disappointment
and suffering
and the freedom i found was in hey
embracing this bernardo doesn't even
exist
of course he's not in control i am a
doing i am a process
something wants to manifest through this
doing
and as the doing i'm not going to resist
it i'll let it through
and and i and look if it works great
if it doesn't work it's not my problem
either
because the you know the same argument
that tells you
you're not in control also tells you you
do not
really have ultimate responsibility
that's not a license for immoral
or dysfunctional behavior that's not a
license
for dysfunctional behavior or a criminal
behavior let me repeat it
it's not a license for that it just
tells you
if you regret anything you're deluding
yourself because you didn't choose what
you regret
either something worked through you
something needed to happen through your
actions
so you know the illusion of control is
as much an illusion
and for the same reasons of the illusion
of
regret so yeah i don't understand that
last point about regret
you can only regret things if you think
you really had a choice and you made the
wrong one
right now if you understand that there
was a natural process unfolding
over which the thing you consider to be
yourself was just as a small part and
that the boundaries between that and the
rest
it's just a narrative in your head yeah
and a mental configuration that is
conducive to that narrative
then no regret what is there to regret
it's not your show you know what i mean
this is where i'm thinking about what's
the confluence between
the judeo-christian ethic and then the
east and i see overlap and then i see
disparity
so one is the surrendering there's that
seems to be common to all religions
now in christianity it's like surrender
to the truth and that's something
jesus i try yeah but jesus is synonymous
with the truth and love
yeah exactly jesus is the word the lord
so surrender to jesus seems like
something very concrete and personal
it's saying the same thing that the
eastern guys are saying all there is is
the void you don't even exist it's
the same bloody evening but even the
rationalists too
where the rationalists talk about well
all i follow is logic well the root word
of logic is logos and you hear what they
say about logic it's almost
equivalent to what christians have to
say about jesus that is it's it's all
perva oh
god it's all pervading you k it's a
natural order you cannot go against it
okay well you can go against it actually
but you you're it's deleterious if you
go against it just like some
rationalists say well if that's
illogical dismiss that
okay so then the surrendering to the
truth okay that's
that's something i try i try to live my
life by i do
i do like that i do
like i i hope that i do live that live
by that
and and then the truth has to be
selected by something
what i mean by that is that there's an
infinite amount of truths to choose from
so you have to have some selection
mechanism
and then that selection mechanism has to
be well i
conceptualize it as love so of all the
truths
so here's one way of talking about it
someone close to me said
i wanted to tell my partner she's as
cold as a rock
something like that and then i was
thinking well
you shouldn't say that and then i think
i said that then he said but it's true
and it's like well it is true because
she is cold she is as cold as a rock
but it's not loving and there's plenty
you could say so why would you select
that one
okay so there's that you surrender to
the truth i like that and then
in christianity there is an emphasis on
on slavery in the sense that
be a slave to a higher master and then
that can obviously get
distorted and being used for actual
stuff you nailed it right you nailed it
you hit it
in the head in your first words thanks
thanks thanks
okay but then here's the difference you
said regret
and regret is something that we did not
choose but in the christian ethic i
would
imagine for your choices yeah yes yes
yes you choose correctly
and you can regret and that's fine don't
make that same mistake again
and as long as you don't make it again
jesus forgot as long as you want to
live your life by not making that
mistake again that's forgiveness you
don't need to regret it
if you regret it well who are you to
even regret it jesus forgives you you
know better than jesus
so in some way you can let go of regret
like that so it's complimentary but then
i
the east and the west but then i see the
differences
i think all religious traditions that
have
moved a significant number of people in
our history
they have the power they have
the power to compel people to move in a
certain way they have that power because
they are
touching on something true although
amenable to wild misinterpretation
but at the source it's pure at the
source it is the truth
and what you just said in christianity
it's all about surrendering to a higher
power
and that's exactly and i can recognize
what happened in my life
over the past year as an instance of
that
because by i by admitting and facing the
reality that pernamcas took not only is
not in control has never been
but is not really even there that was my
freedom
it's this recognition that is freeing
not
the freedom of control but the freedom
of surrender
surrendering to a higher power and that
higher power is what i really
am it's nature as it wants to manifest
through me
so i i recognize the christian
surrendering to yourself
you're certainly what you actually are
truest you're natural
as opposed to your adaptive self your
your social socially adaptive self
because it sounds selfish
it sounds narcissistic like i'm
surrendering to myself i'll do what i
will but side
yeah it's a precise opposite of that so
why do you think
sorry to interrupt but this is like and
i know you got to go man like
i've kept you on for way too long and
i'm
like i should get going at some point
too but why do you think
it is that the east managed to get the
metaphysic correct
know their coach by chance yeah i know
but what is it about
this that's the biggest question right
this is a dangerous path
because it starts getting into and do
different so-called races have different
potentials
and i don't even acknowledge
scientifically the existence of a race
so i'm not going to say that there's
something special
about the peoples of the subcontinent i
don't think that would be
a statement i would espouse
but i do recognize that for whatever
reason
it has happened there and the true
understanding of
it still seems to occur more often
there to this darn day
now i would not offer you an explanation
along genetic lines of superiority or
anything
because i don't believe in this kind of
explanations but
yeah it's a confluence in nature
that happened to happen there and and
still happening there and might think
well it's a long time for it to be just
a confluence
it's not it's three and a half thousand
years it's the blink of an eye it's less
than the blink of an eye
it's like nothing you know and it may be
different
next time around i don't know we will
not be
around in this form and to see that in
this form um
so i i do not know why there
you know that that period of time is
called the
the axial age um
and it's a mystery why then and why in
many parts of the world but particularly
stronger than anywhere else and arguably
truer than anywhere else that this
happened in the
hindus valley and the only explanation i
i can conceive is it's another culture
and which is true it's another culture
you know where the subcontinent was when
europe was in the dark ages
it's not a very flattering comparison
for europe um you're talking about minus
3000 bc now i'm talking about already
the dark ages in europe you know
the period between 400 and 1400 when
intellectual development stopped
in europe social development stopped in
europe was in the dark ages in the
subcontinent
it was not dark in in the muslim world
it was not dark either
actually it was a sort of renaissance
of arts crafts and science in the muslin
world
um so you know the the the
torch of wisdom
and intellectual development is hand
over
across the world in different epochs
i do acknowledge that metaphysical
understanding
seems to particularly correlate with the
subcontinent you know for whatever
reason and i i don't know
i don't know i i would tell you this if
i were
someone from the subcontinent you're
from the sub-continent aren't you your
surname
my my background is west indian so i'm
from trinidad and then i
am an immigrant to toronto so i came
here when i was yeah okay so you have
that background
if i had that background i'll not
how will i get across by saying that if
i had that background i would be proud
oh that's nice i'll put it that way but
that doesn't mean that
that i intellectually think that the
races
are superior i don't i think this is
nonsense yeah i wasn't gonna go there
well what i was wondering is so one
explanation is by chance and the reasons
by chance is
we can say that it's been around for
3000 years so it can't be by chance
because that's too long but then at the
same time time is relative like it's a
blink in the eye who knows
another role of the dice maybe african
culture would have come up with
christianity and
vice versa and so on blah blah blah okay
cool it's not only that it that it arose
there i mean it popped elsewhere it
popped in western culture as well
parmenides arguably was an idealist if
you interpret him correctly
as uh um is that a pre-socratic
yeah yeah okay yeah i don't know um so
it sounds like basically
it popped elsewhere um so it's not
exclusive to the subcontinent what makes
the subcontinent
special is that it was conducive to its
spread and adoption
instead of popping the minds of one
another and then disappearing
like in the west there it popped and
took hold
so there was an easier recognition of
that and
yeah was that cultural i don't know it
predates assault so you can't even make
historical arguments about the alignment
of philosophy and state power because it
precedes that
so i don't know i don't know okay i know
you got to get going
so how about i just read to you a few
questions and then you answer them
quickly
because there are some audience
questions so one
you mentioned that materialism if we
guide ourselves by that we're doomed
i'm curious is there no case to be made
for ethics
under materialism like some would say
like marxists
i think i think morals and ethics are
are practical useful constructs and
there is just
as good a case for a functional moral
anathex under materialism as there is
under any other
metaphysics so yes i don't think an
argument against materialism is that
it's not conducive to ethics i don't
think that is true i think we can live
ethically and morally
also under materialism i think
materialism is killing for
meaning for our sense of meaning and for
our understanding of our place in nature
materialism is killing for that it's a
nihilistic philosophy
but it's not a philosophy that makes
functional morals and ethics impossible
i don't think that is the case and i
think it's a fallacious argument against
materialism
in other words i don't think a
materialist is necessarily a bad person
what is the weakest point of your theory
slash worldview so that is
if someone was to put a crack in it
where would they most likely
to be successful putting a crack in it's
uh
an explicit conceptual account of
exactly what dissociation is
we know it exists because of empirical
reasons it is happening we have
neural imaging studies of person with
dissociate people with dissociation
we know the dreams they report that they
can experience the dream from different
point of views depending on the altar
so we know that the process exists that
is necessary to explain
nature so it is there we know
empirically
but we do not have a explicit completely
internally consistent
conceptual account of it that's the
weakest point
i would say that's not a reason to
reject idealism because whether we have
a conceptual account of it or not we
know the process exists
so this is an epistemic question with
very
little force you know whether we can
whether we can account for it for it or
not we know it exists accountability is
an issue
when you're postulating things that you
don't know whether they exist or not
then you have to describe them
explicitly and completely
for us check the plausibility of it but
when nature is already showing us
this happens that's all we need but i
would admit
that we lack a complete and internally
consistent
conceptual account of exactly what the
association is
what makes something living versus not
conscious versus not so
is a brick alive and how do we have a
way of
drawing that boundary is there something
special about biological life
why what are the conditions you just
mentioned this right like what are the
conditions for the sophisticated
dissociation let's say
i think all biology is the image of a
dissociative process in
the natural mind so to say um or
universal consciousness if i want if i
use some
terms co-opted by the new age
i think all matter is the image of inner
mental processes the question is
what counts as a dissociated alter and
what is just
part of the rest of mind at large as a
whole
because mind at large technically is
also an altar
not in other words after you eliminate
every living being what remains is
itself an
altar because it's dissociated from the
living beings
so if there is a dissociative boundary
there is an outer
and any boundary divides the spacing two
so when you have a boundary you have at
least
two altars already so at the birth of
the first living being
in the history of the universe there
were two outers
the living being and all the rest which
was dissociated from the living being
the association is two ways
to stop you i'm trying to understand
you're making a distinction between
living
and mind so can you experience without
living
yes i think the rest of the universe the
inanimate universe everything that
remains after you remove every living
being
everything that remains is itself a
conscious entity
okay bernardo sorry i'm trying to
understand this forgive me if i just
keep interrupting
okay are you making a connection between
living beings and self-conscious beings
or those two separate
yes i think only the altars
that correspond to living beings have
developed
self-consciousness because you need
evolution by natural selection in in in
the
framework of a planetary ecosystem for
this to evolve
so i don't think mind at large in other
words the parts of universal
consciousness that
are dissociated from all living beings
what remains of the universe after you
account for all living beings
i don't think mind at large is
self-conscious
because it didn't undergo the pressures
of natural selection in a planetary
ecosystem it had no reason
to need to evolve that higher order
mental
ability um but i think it is conscious
because all there is
is consciousness and you may call it god
if you want
it's certainly omnipresent and probably
omniscient
even though not not self-reflective
and also omnipotent although not in a
premeditated way
so i'm fine if you want to call that god
with the caveat that that's what i mean
by the word god and not anything else
um and it is conscious too so and what
does it look like from our perspective
it looks like the inanimate universe
stars galaxies quasars black holes moons
asteroids everything that is known
living around us
is the body of mind at large in other
words
it's what the innermantation of mind at
large looks like when observed from
across
our dissociative boundary it's what the
mental inner life of mind at large looks
like to us
in the dashboard of our sensory organs
so all matter is just the image of
conscious in their life whether it
corresponds to a living being or not and
here i'm
restricting the term life to dissociated
alters
and the inanimate universe in that sense
is not alive because it's not an
organism
but it has mental inner life conscious
in their life
and now i'm using the word life in a
broader sense it is conscious but it's
not a living organism in a restricted
the restrictive definition of a living
organism as something that metabolizes
the inanimate universe does not
metabolize but i do think it has
conscious in their life
and that's the matter of the inanimate
universe is what that conscious in their
life looks like
in the dashboard of the dials that we
use to collect information from what's
outside our altar
on the other side of our dissociative
boundary so
everything betrays the presence of
consciousness literally everything the
question is
is what betrays the presence of
dissociated conscious processes
then i would say only living beings do
that this bottle
does not have a conscious inner life in
and of itself the way you have a
conscious inner life in and of itself
i think this bottle is part of the broad
image we call the inanimate universe
and the inanimate universe is conscious
as a whole
in other words there is no bottle it's a
linguistic
differentiation we make the only
ontologically distinct
things are living beings why because i
fear if i pinch my skin and i don't feel
it if i pinch my screen
so there is an ontological boundary
defining my outer and that is
the boundaries of what i can directly
feel i don't feel photons hitting
against the wall but i feel photons
hitting against my retina so there is an
ontake
way to say this is a this is something
separate but
we do not have any reason to pronounce
that the car is separate
that the road is separate that the empty
bottle of water is separate
these are linguistic distinctions we
call it nominal separations
they are merely nominal we we apply
these for convenience so we can
communicate more easily if i want to buy
a car but
the car is continuous with the rest of
the inanimate universe
if you take away the road and the
gravity that pulls the car against the
road
the car doesn't go anywhere it doesn't
move if you take away the wear
the air that allows for combustion in
the engine it doesn't even fire
so there is no proper grounds for
distinguishing between inanimate objects
so if you ask me
does the bottle have conscious in their
life of its own
i would say no because the bottle isn't
even a bottle
it's a nominal distinction we make there
is only the inanimate universe
as a whole and that yes that has a
conscious inner life of its own
dissociated from us
what type of logic do you subscribe to
classical intuitionist
so i'm an i'm an intuitionist i think uh
the the law of excluded middle although
seems to be very intuitive um
it is not well formed i think it doesn't
survive proper scrutiny
i think existence can only be
demonstrated by the production of an
example
of that which you want to say exists as
opposed to
abstractly proving the impossibility of
non-existence
if you use the words intuitionist then
you know what i'm talking about
maybe for the benefit of the audience
the law of excluded middle says
that either something is true or false
it cannot be both
either something exists or it doesn't
exist it cannot do both
so by proving that something cannot be
false
you indirectly prove it to be true
that's aristotelian logic
if you reject the law of excluded middle
then proving the impossibility of
something being false
does not prove that it's true an
intuitionist would say you can only
prove it to be true
if you produce an instance of it if you
construct
it and i think that that's what is
ultimately true uh mind at large
does not follow the law of excluded
middle i think you see you know
people who undergo experiences of
altered states
they come back and say that was
completely logical but so real
what they are referring to is that the
law of excluded middle didn't apply so
aristotelian logic didn't apply
but things exist by virtue
of an instance of them being produced in
other words thing only exists
when they actually exist as opposed to
their abstract non-existence being
disproven according to some conceptual
system formal system so i reject that
and i'm an intuitionist
yeah not to lower in estimation you're
suffering from tinnitus but there
if you think that's bad try having a
math professor who's an intuitionist
logic
person making you construct from scratch
and not allow proofs by contradiction
there you go okay so you also mentioned
one time when you were talking to
steve patterson from patterson pursuits
or patterson in pursuit
that what we're doing right now me and
you we're speaking in the
domain of rationality and reason and
logic evidence so and so on
rupert spira who you spoke who you would
speak to wouldn't
even buy into that game you're playing
in a different arena but you said that
what i'm doing or sorry you said that
what you're doing is
this is the norm so you have to play in
this game but you ultimately
believe it's incomplete and this is not
the game we should be playing so to make
an analogy
it would be like you're trying to best
someone at soccer to show them that
basketball is better so then what i'm
wondering is okay so what is the
game of all games the game of all games
is
knowledge by acquaintance not knowledge
by conceptualization concepts only point
at something but they are not the thing
they are pointing
at right so to know the truth
conceptually
means that you know the direction it's
pointing to but you're not acquainted
with the truth
until it's embodied so you may be
convinced that something is true but
it's not in your body and doesn't change
your life and doesn't make you feel
differently
so you may be intellectually convinced
materialism is false but you still may
dread
the oblivion of your consciousness
coming upon death
in other words you didn't embody your
intellectual conclusion what's governing
your emotional life
it's something else it's not your
intellectual conclusion the conclusion
didn't sink from here
down to the emotional self so it's not
really transformative it's not guiding
your life
now i play purely an intellectual game
rupert spyra rupert plays the game of
embodied truth
he's not trying to convince you
intellectually at all he completely
bypasses that he neglects that
he's trying to bring you truth by
acquaintance in other words if you
experience
oneness you do not need a narrative that
tells you that one is true you've been
there
it's in you no you short circuit it you
bypass it
that's his game and it's the only game
that is truly transformative that will
really change your life everything else
is in the head
it doesn't sink into the rest so why do
i play the intellectual game
because i think that a lot of people who
are perfectly capable of knowing the
truth by acquaintance
and who would have known the truth by
acquaintance don't
because their intellect is the bouncer
of their heart
they will not give themselves permission
to be acquainted with what's true
because the intellect is telling them no
this cannot be true
and that's that evil little voice like
this cannot be true
it cannot be the case so it's not and
that closes you up
and it amputates a huge part of your
mind
of your capability to experience uh
what's actually going on it is
shut off um by an intellectual
conclusion which is not
in itself transformative but it can
amputate the degrees of freedom
that you're true in your life your
emotion in your life would otherwise
have it cuts up the map and offers you a
much more restricted territory that you
can explore
and makes you blind and inaccessible to
the rest and therefore it precludes you
from
becoming acquainted with what is true
because you don't give yourself
intellectual permission
to become acquainted with it so i play
the intellectual game because i want to
help people give themselves intellectual
permission
to explore the fullness of their nature
as living beings as dissociated outers
because the
dissociated outer while it's alive it's
dissociated but even in that state of
dissociation
it can become acquainted with things
that
our mainstream cultural narrative
categorically today says
are either impossible or if they
actually happen
illusory and therefore should be
dismissed
and not taken seriously and that is the
greatest
tragedy of our age that not only do we
know where the solutions lie
but that we actually every now and then
experience the solution
but dismiss it because of this
pernicious cultural narrative that tells
us what can and cannot be true
you mentioned you had a great phrase i
don't know if you just came up with it
the intellectual side is the bouncer of
the heart
yeah i often used this in this one okay
that's a great one i haven't heard that
now should the heart be the ultimate
adjudicator that is
don't let the authoritative judgment go
to the intellect but
only let it be the heart is there a mix
and then what decides that mix
something above both heart and intellect
the heart is a metaphor what i mean is
your true emotional life how you
how you actually feel irrespective of
what you think you should be feeling
you see what i mean we often tell
ourselves well my life is
is great um everything is in order and
yet i'm massively depressed
and and you can't pin it down your
intellect doesn't have an answer because
according to the intellect everything is
okay
but your true feelings are what counts
they are your true self
the intellect is a construct on top of
it uh
your emotions are the foundation and
they are ultimately your real life and
you cannot escape that so the heart is a
metaphor for that
maybe more than that maybe the heart is
the image of that particular
part that particular configuration of
mind um
but um well that wouldn't i mean
technically that wouldn't be the case
unless you want to make a case that
people with pacemakers lack
so heart is a metaphor for your true
emotional inner life and then you say
well should that be the judge i would
say
the question is unnecessary because
it is how you feel so you don't really
have a choice there
do i choose to feel that way or not and
that's that's our dilemma we think the
intellect has a choice
as a say on that that if we tell
ourselves i achieved everything i wanted
so i should be happy and therefore i am
happy well
guess what you don't get to choose you
may achieve everything you think you
wanted
and you still may be massively depressed
inside because the life you truly live
is the life of how you feel not the life
of what you think
so you know in that sense the heart is
the master whether you admit it or not
whether you want it or not
whether you can rationalize it or not
you are living your heart by definition
what you leave is your heart not what
you think when the intellect is in
charge quote unquote it's because the
heart let it be
no well it's never in charge you always
feel the way you feel
regardless of what you think about it
but i'm taking this bouncer
analogy too far then that no no no no
no you feel the way you feel
but you could feel differently if only
your intellect would give you permission
to experience that
other thing so the intellect is a filter
but it's not how you feel
you feel the way you feel
what your intellect thinks may correlate
with how you feel
but that correlation usually that works
the way it usually works the way around
you feel the way you feel and then you
look for an intellectual explanation for
why you feel the way you feel
yeah but the other way around doesn't
work you can't
tell yourself to be happy you can't
convince yourself that you are happy
um but if you are unhappy and you could
come out of unhappiness by exploring
a previously unknown room in the mansion
of your mind the intellect
make the intellect doesn't really close
that door to you
but it convince you that it's
unnecessary to open it
was there a moment or an insight that
brought you from that place of suffering
that you experienced about a year to
three years ago
to now or was it a gradual process
gradual process
yeah it happens under your nose you
cannot you only see it in hindsight you
look back and
oh i have been feeling different for a
few months now oh
interesting how is it that you get your
ideas writ
sorry how is it that you formulate your
ideas see for me
writing is something that i have to
force myself to do
in the sense that i made it a habit so
now i do it each morning
but i had to tell myself to do that
ideas come to me somewhat naturally and
i just write it down on my
on my phone so that they just spew out
at any moment
even right now it's it's frantic but
writing itself is a it's a chore i have
to force myself to do it
so how is it that you write and
formulate your sorry what i'm trying to
say is
do your ideas come almost ready made and
then it's just a matter of typing them
out
or does the writing process help clarify
refine and what does that look like is
it just you rewriting you re you
just you vomited out onto the paper at
first and then you
fix the mess like pretty much please
take me through your process of writing
it's not a choice it doesn't happen at
the time or form
of my choosing so the ideas just
come with an overwhelming force that
makes me feel very small
but the writing process does help
articulate the ideas in words
it helps me tell myself what it is
that that i think i know
you know what i mean because it's one
thing to have an understanding and it's
another thing entirely different
to tell yourself in words what it is
that you think you understand
so the ideas come as that instantaneous
understanding
boom there may be three volumes in that
but i cannot tell myself what it is that
i understood
until i go through the writing process
ah that's super interesting
because to me i wouldn't phrase it like
that i would say that i don't understand
it until i can write it out and
reread it and then it makes sense like
to me i can feel like i understood it
but it's an amorphous mess
of intuition and that's and i guess what
you're doing is you're listening to your
heart you're saying well
you intuit it you're correct and i'm
saying
no i could be a choice it's not even a
choice because
as i'm writing the reason i say that the
idea comes
all formed is that if i immediately
start writing
i know in a
in an overwhelming way whether i am what
i am writing
uh is correct or not uh
in other words whether before you write
it
during the writing if i if i get too
lost in my thoughts and i lose contact
with the original idea that it's still
sitting like a ball of hot iron
somewhere here
um if i deviate from that very quickly
i read what i i read what i wrote and i
go like no no that's not it that's not
it so the the reference is always there
from the beginning it's like i always
know where i wrote [ __ ]
or whether i wrote something that does
justice to what
to to that intuition so that's what
leads me to tell you that
the knowledge is there from from moment
zero
because i can always compare that
against
that feeling and know whether i'm
writing nonsense or whether i'm doing
justice to it
so from that point on the work becomes
one of labor
it's giving words to it but it helps me
reconcile myself with that thing that
comes
because it allows me to tell myself in
words what it is that i think i
understood
know what i mean and for me as as an ego
this wording to myself of what i think i
understand is very important that
um if for as long as i'm not able to do
that
i feel an enormous urgency
that doesn't let me sleep doesn't let me
focus on anything else in life
i only buy myself out of that i only buy
my freedom
once it's all laid out in words and then
i feel like i've been released
it's like someone was holding a leash i
was leashed
and and once i do that i get my ticket
to freedom and i'm let go
until the next book comes um so it
it's not glamorous at all it's not
spiritual
and you know what i mean it's it's not
this romantic
vision we have about the muse and the
intuition
and something coming to the world
through you well guess what that's
exactly what happened something comes to
the
to the world through you you are an
instrument but there is nothing romantic
about it it's
it's it's gritty it's sweaty
it's cruel um not glamorous
not romantic and not spiritual it's like
you just want to get rid of that
ball of hot iron you want to vomit it
out and and
be rid of it and and be free for a
little while until the next one comes
um that has always been my relationship
with my writing the
impression i have is that this stuff is
not me at all
this stuff is there pregnant somewhere
uh
in in the framework behind space and
time
it's sitting there and it wants to erupt
like it wants to go through a volcano
like the lava building pressure
underneath
it wants to erupt but it doesn't find a
channel you know what i mean
interesting then i just happened to pass
by
and now going about my business and then
oh that guy that guy would do he has
some conceptual armor
that will allow the translation of this
hot iron this hot
lava stuff which was a metaphor jung
himself used
this lava stuff you'll be able to give
it words so that's the instrument
so no put him on a leash don't let him
go he will be a hard slave
now that i'm i'm speaking metaphorically
but that's how it feels like i was in
the wrong place at the wrong time and i
got
caught and and now i'm stuck
just because you have the right
preconditions for it so yeah the way
that i'm making an analogy in my head is
not with a
volcano but with lightning and it has
some charges built up some potential and
now it's looking for some place where
can it release
it yeah then it's all resistance and it
hurts and it was me
something about my background uh
computer engineering artificial
intelligence on the one hand but a lot
of philosophical receptive on the other
lived in four countries thinking three
languages
something about that probably made me
the
the path of least resistance for
lightning and then it struck through me
now look the metaphor is great in this
sense it doesn't feel good
to have lightening fast not for you it
feels horrible and um and again only
this year i made peace with it
i stopped fighting it uh i stopped
thinking of it as
this responsibility i didn't want to
have this this
thing that makes me unable to enjoy life
it gives me meaning
and i'm eternally grateful for that my
life
never lacks meaning and that's the most
important thing
but it has not been pleasant for the
longest of times
and the making peace with that and that
that's what i call the freedom of the
slave
when the slave find finds his freedom
in a in a two by two meter cubicle
without a window
now you're free man nobody can take that
freedom from you if you find that
freedom
as a slave leeched in a cubicle without
a window
if you find it there it can never
be taken away from you and i'm glowing
about it now because it's so recent and
i'm sure i'll be very cynical about it a
couple of years from now and
life will be rotten again and somebody
will get cancer or i or i'll lose
somebody i love and it will be [ __ ]
again
but right now i'm glowing because i
found the freedom of the slave i stopped
pulling on the leash
so i don't get hurt anymore
and by you doing so see carl jung when
you read
you've read jung three times i've barely
read
a percentage of his work because it's so
difficult but when you read jung almost
every other sentence
is like a perfect quotation and he had
one that i
try to live my life by see i used to be
and i still am but i used to be much
much much more egotistical and arrogant
and think
that much like you when you're 34 and on
top of the world and owning a company
i'm not saying that you were anywhere
near as megalo maniacal as i am
or was but but i would would think that
i want to change the world and i would
think of myself as such a
a savior i'd have such a savior complex
like i'm going to end suffering i'm
going to
i'm going to solve global warming and
and even stop animals for harming each
other and give
clean water to the rest of the world
some part of that there's a good
motivation but a large part of it was
unconsciously i want to be worshiped as
the savior i want people to come to me
say thank you so much kurt
and that's that was hard for me to it's
even hard for me to admit right now
saying it out loud carl jung said that
you can't
in some ways see this is what's so
tricky about it's like carl jung would
say you can't save someone
but then that means like well what if
they're dying on the ocean you're not
going to pull them out
what if someone's on fire well it's more
like psychologically you can't save
someone
you could only carry your own cross
and hopefully by example you show them
how to burden theirs yes
that's part one so yeah hopefully some
of what i'm doing with this podcast even
with talking to you and admitting my
faults and
and and my
me saying that i don't know me not
knowing much
and trying to understand these
variegated
fields and philosophies and fix myself
in the process hopefully
i can i can i can
shoulder my cross and maybe some people
can find
some example in that kurt if i if i may
tell you something from the heart
i don't know how you he will receive it
um
it would have helped me when i was in a
similar spot
so i'll tell you what would have helped
me which doesn't mean it will help you
at all
i would say this my mature self would
say this to my
last mature self don't make it too
complicated
just don't take yourself too seriously
it is not all about you
you are not the sum total of what's
going on
if you don't see the meaning don't worry
about it you don't need to
you are immersed in an infinite ocean
of mystery which is touching your skin
right now
and you cannot escape it there are
things
that you would want to know and you
can't even articulate the question
and you're immersed in it it's hugging
you at all times whether you want it or
not it's right on the other side of your
skin
um it is what you are ultimately
so just relax don't take yourself too
seriously
what's going on is beyond what your
little human rational mind
can ever corral in the little
story um and and you gotta have
faith in in the true religious sense
which is
trust that that which you don't know and
you're immersed then all this mystery
is going somewhere worthwhile and if
it's not
there's nothing to lose so there's no
price to be paid for being wrong
regarding this
so he might as well have faith don't
take don't take yourself too seriously
and just have faith it will go the way
it will go then it will be fine
thank you even in that like you got to
put up some resistance but even in that
you have some conviction
you know what you're saying and you
believe it which means you have a
framework through which to interpret the
world even if that framework
has as a part of it that i can never
know or comprehend
the vast majority of it i think my
biggest knowledge is knowing what i
don't know
oh no not even that because not even
that i know is knowing how
much i don't know and and there is
freedom
in recognizing that because a lot of
anxiety
and nihilism has to do with a certain
narrative
about what things are and you think you
know them
and that's what's confining that's what
is so crushing
when you think you know and you think
the mystery is off the table
when you think that the air you're
breathing right now has been fully
explained
each molecule in the air you're
breathing
it is a mystery of unfathomable
depth and it's percolating
through your body right now so
the ego thinks it will find freedom by
controlling and knowing
while freedom is found in being aware of
how much you do not know
and allowing it to play out in other
words i'm not saying this because i know
a lot
i'm saying this because i am more aware
now of how much i don't know
than i was before i thought i knew a
whole bunch of stuff
now i know that what i think i knew what
i thought i know
sorry what i thought i knew is just
images
phantasms representations appearances
how things present themselves to me not
what they are in and of themselves
i've realized that what my sensorium
gives me is a dashboard
not a clear glass window in into what is
out there
and when you realize that every
lightning strike
is a mystery of cosmic proportions of a
divine
nature let alone quasars and black holes
it brings you to tears a dark cloud in
the sky is enough to
to move you to to to use a christian
language to throw yourselves to your
knees and and thank god for existence
this realization of the unfathomable
mystery
that is surrounding and and
caressing you for lack of a better word
at all times it is that unknowing that
lack of control that acceptance of
our slavery condition as natural
processes that don't really exist but
through which nature
expresses something it is this unknowing
lack of control and acceptance that
at least for me that has bought me some
temporary freedom for all i know after
we
this conversation i will get a phone
call that will destroy my life
and i will and i will want to kill
myself for all you know that will be the
case but you know
right now that's my freedom why did you
laugh right there when you said for all
i know i'll get a phone call and i'll
destroy my life and then you like
now freud would say that that's
indicative of something unconscious but
i'm sure that that's i'm reading too
much into it like i'm i'm
thinking too much because i'm curious it
was irony it's the irony of knowing that
morals are human constructs just like
our sense of fairness
that in nature there is no such thing as
justice and fairness
i'm just such a selfish person bernard
like it's so
no i mean like i i'm almost like
confessing like if it's a
like if you're a priest i i i wish i had
the peace that
now see what's so tricky about this is
that
i'm also being overly hard on myself
partly because i want to just express
the worst parts worst parts of me
because i'm
somewhat afraid of of seeming arrogant
and expressing the parts of me that i
i find that i'm proud of so for example
each year of my life since i was 26
has just gotten progressively better and
better and better and i'm married
and i love my life and i find like every
i
love work i love love love love work
like i love talking to you
love talking to you i love studying to
talk to you i love studying to talk to
other people i love talking to those
i love my wife and i'm so
fortunate that all i have in my life is
my clean apartment
like my clean condo super clean i have
a taxi a phobia so i don't like
disorderliness or un
tidiness and everything's in its own
place i have a
i have a toyota corolla like a 2021
hybrid toyota i love my toyota corolla
to some people it's like oh who cares
about that oh i love it love
love everything about my life i feel
like almost each moment is imbued with
such meaning
so when i say that i'm a selfish person
and i and i express that
i am lacking in some way i i
i'm not falling apart but i i think i
come across or i let that part of me be
seen
more readily because i'm afraid
of seeming like i have it all together
and seeming arrogant and i'm
there's a part of me that's so afraid of
that and i well i'm just confessing i
don't
have a question formulated around that
you're being uh
human and you said that yes i take
myself too seriously so like
okay i don't think i do
but i'm sure i do because you're wiser
than i am and
you must see it and so if
we're worried about what other people
think of you you're taking yourself too
seriously
if it would destroy your life to be
humiliated in public
you're taking yourself too seriously
because for nature
it's just a natural process unfolding
everything else is a narrative we place
on it
a value-based judgment of our own
invention and that that that's why that
little cynic
yeah cynical ironic love i gave
because you know when you get to the
point where i am
there is a temptation to say i've went
i've gone through [ __ ]
now i've arrived in a place of peace it
would be unfair if this were taken from
me
now and then the next part is yeah it's
okay
it's a cosmic giggle you know it would
be taken from you next
second if that's how nature wants to
unfolding to unfold
there is no such thing as justice there
is only
a conceptualization of people who take
themselves too seriously now that
doesn't mean that i want to defend
myself
or my girlfriend if somebody threatens
her safety i will kill to defend her
so i will act to preserve my
functional status i will i will act to
preserve my life
my security my comfort but that too
is a natural process i will not be doing
that out of some sense of
intrinsic cosmic justice and god as a
judge that will you know pass judgment
fairly
across all involved i don't think that's
what's going on i think nature can be
just as cruel as an ironic as
any human being can so that that's why i
had that
little ironic giggle because i'm in a
good place right now but i'm
keenly aware the carpet can be pulled
out
of my feet
30 seconds from now i may get the phone
call you know destroy my world
you have such a great great great great
outlook and
see for me i've been so humiliated and
humbled
and i don't i don't particularly mind
public humiliation
and i've done enough self-development to
overcome some of that
where you just do push-ups on the street
or you yell for no reason or whatever it
may be
but maybe a part of my background
anxiety
is the fact that i either one feel bad
that i have such a great great great
great great
life and that not only is there so much
suffering but
it could be else and at any moment
i know that there were other points in
my life where
right when i thought i had it figured
out is when it all falls apart
and so maybe i'm wondering do i have it
too good
and then i i'm wondering like i might
just think i'm thinking myself into my
own suffering but i'm not suffering that
much like i'm
i'm way overblowing it
maybe i want a question we should honor
our suffering
even if you say well other people have
it a lot worse than me and
and i'm saying this because i'm guilty
of it all the time i always tell myself
well my suffering is nothing compared to
the suffering syria
to the sufferings bangladesh to the
suffering in africa but
in that sense i don't do justice to
myself because you know
for good or bad reason i do suffer
so yeah i wouldn't go there but look the
the most
you know what the most insidious form of
taking yourself too seriously is
is when you tell yourself [ __ ] i take
myself too seriously and i shouldn't
that's the worst instance of taking
yourself too seriously
because if you don't take yourself too
seriously you are kind towards yourself
it is taking yourself too seriously to
say i'm taking myself too seriously yeah
yeah okay okay please explain because
you told me that so now if i was to
listen to it are you telling myself
because if you think if you think it's
so important
that you shouldn't take yourself so
seriously
then you are taking yourself too
seriously otherwise you would say
yeah okay i'm taking myself so seriously
it's what is
right i take myself too seriously yeah
yeah
okay man you have something you're like
oh [ __ ]
i'm taking myself too seriously and i
shouldn't i have to do something about
it what do you think that is
it's you taking yourself extra seriously
okay so not taking yourself too
seriously entails doesn't imply it
entails being kind to yourself giving
yourself a pass
forgiving you know yeah yeah you're much
more much more wise
than i and i know you got to go and i'm
sorry i keep you
i want to tell you
and i want to give you a piece of
imagery i was watching the da vinci code
and the first one there's this guy you
look like neil patrick's harris harris
neil patrick harris he had
he's like pale skinned white okay and
he was just praying yeah okay he's
praying he's praying and he's taking a
whip and chastising himself
like self-mortification and then he's
portrayed as the crazy one
because of that and i remember watching
that movie and thinking
no we're the crazy ones because we're
not taking life seriously
this guy is atoning for each sin
painfully and
specifically and i and i'm like that's
like i wish i was as courageous as that
now
you're probably hearing that and
thinking i'm i'm worshiping the wrong
god in a sense
i think there is a crucial distinction
between taking yourself too seriously
and taking life seriously
i wouldn't do the former but i
absolutely recommend the latter
taking yourself too seriously is not
helpful neither to nature
nor to what you think you are taking
life seriously is a whole other game
it's very important
in some sense you can only take life
seriously if you don't take
yourself too seriously because if
yourself consumes life
then you're not taking life seriously
life is something that happens
through you if you make it all about
you you're not making it about life
do you see what i mean okay see tony
robbins has this phrase
life is not happening to you it's
happening for you but then you've just
put a twist on that
or an ancient twist but you're saying
it's not happening to you nor is it
happening for you it's happening through
you yeah tony robbins and and
a lot of the self self-help
literature and a lot of the new age and
spiritual literature
it's all about consolation by creating
the illusion that your ego
is in control of the world and that the
universe is some kind of menu
and you can just place your order and if
you place your order in just the right
way by thinking the right thoughts and
applying the right techniques then you
get everything your ego wants
i personally think that's [ __ ]
utter complete and unhelpful
the meaning [ __ ] um i don't think
that's the way to go it's destructive
too not just
destructive yeah yeah it elevates the
ego
to to the position of king of an
illusory reality
and it will hurt you ultimately although
it may give you a sense a
sense of comfort in the beginning short
term right and it will wreck the planet
if everybody tries to do that
so i look look when i told you i don't
don't take yourself too seriously i
didn't mean not to take life seriously
on the contrary
i think life is to be taken very
seriously and the way to go about it
is to let it flow through you and not
try to wrestle control of it and make it
about yourself
are just a few questions from the
audience and i want to ask you them you
could just answer them shortly i know
you got a question we've gone so far
so okay i might as well just a few more
minutes right khalil
and danny phd islamic studies that's
his username says dr castro if mind at
large is active evolving and excited as
reflected in natural processes
doesn't your model still need to account
for a higher level explanation or cause
for this activity
can you repeat the question yeah i'm not
sure i understood it so i copy and
pasted it and
thought maybe when i read it out loud it
would make sense dr castro
if life is evolving if it's active it's
excited as reflected in natural
processes
doesn't your model still need to account
for a higher
yeah i don't think so i think
life is doing what it's doing or the
universe is doing what it's doing
because it is what it is it's an
implication from identity what the
universe is
determines uh how it will behave
um so it's doing what it's doing because
it is what it is
and we can model that behavior and
predict it
through mathematical equations and
science and all that
but these are models they are not the
reason or the explanation or the impetus
behind
the behavior i think the impetus of the
behavior
is what mind is and if i and i i don't
really think we need more than that in a
sense it's
trying to push reduction beyond where it
needs to go
uh once you get to what the universe is
what else do we need to make sense of
its behavior it's behaving the way
that's because it is what it is
and we can model that behavior and
predict that's all fine
now if the intuition behind the question
is that
there has to be some grander higher
level plan
some some carefully
thought out fine tuning
or or carefully thought out action
i don't think that needs to be the case
i think the unfolding or the the
evolution can be purely instinctive
driven by archetypes and archetypes are
just reflections of what the universe is
um the only point that shuns me a little
bit
is the fine tuning of the universal
constants which which suggests
a ridiculously fine level of planning
if interpreted at face value why are the
universal constants
so exquisitely fine-tuning fine-tuned
to the rise of complexity and life
i don't have an answer to that but the
most promising avenue to make sense of
that
that i have learned of recently is the
work of a physicist called marcus
miller from the austrian academy of
sciences
um we covered his work a lot on the
essentia foundation website
recently and basically what he's saying
is that
from he's a quantum physicist and um his
his take on quantum physics is that the
physical world
is actually created from a first person
perspective
um that we sort of inferentially
build it and then he has a mathematical
argument that if that's what's going on
then we would automatically tend to
infer
physical worlds that are consistent with
each other's in other words you would
construct a personal physical world
of your own i would construct one for
myself through infer
through inference and they would
necessarily
be consistent with one another your
world would be more or less the same as
mine
because of the dynamics of the
inferential processes going on
so basically what he's saying is that
the fine tuning of the universal
constant
that's my interpretation of what he's
saying i asked him the question directly
and he said he hadn't thought about it
yet so i don't want to put these words
in his mouth
my interpretation of what he is doing is
that if
physics arises from a first person
perspective
in other words if the physical world is
emergent
and not absolute which is what quantum
physics is suggesting more than
suggesting right now
um then the fact that
the universal constants are fine-tuned
are either are simply a consequence of
the fact that we
are inferring the physical world so we
would necessarily infer a physical world
that accounts for our existence
because we are the ones inferring it and
therefore the universal constants would
necessarily be fine-tuned
because without it we couldn't account
for our existence so we wouldn't infer
that it sounds like that topic principle
it's a it's uh
it's not quite the entropic principle
but i understand that uh
at first sight it's almost like we're
giving birth to a specific world rather
than
there are a variety of worlds and we're
in the only one that yeah we could
comprehend okay
yes so he's not saying he's not adhering
to solipsism
he admits that you have a conscience in
the life i do and
everybody else does he's not a solipsist
all he's saying is that
the physical world not all possible
worlds but
the physical world arises
through an inferential process we
infer what the physical world is in
order to account for our
own existence and if that happens
then mathematically you can prove that
we would all end up inferring the same
physical world more or less
absolutely interesting so i'll look into
that marcus miller
yeah great okay plastic pairs says
hell yeah right up my alley thanks for
getting bernardo on the show
if consciousness is beyond localization
does that imply that the brain is like a
radio tuner
look i think the radio metaphor is
useful if you're coming from a dualist
background or a pure materialist
background it helps you
think about the issues we are talking
about
i don't think it is ultimately true
though because it's a duelist metaphor
there is the signal and there is the
tuner or
and they are separate things like if if
the brain is a filter
then the brain itself cannot be made of
consciousness otherwise you know
can you talk about a coffee filter made
of coffee you can't it would filter
nothing
a coffee filter made of coffee wouldn't
work um
so if i say that everything is
consciousness and even the brain
is merely the image of certain conscious
processes it's the image of the thing
and as such
it cannot filter consciousness because
it is itself consciousness
now i think what's happening is that the
brain is the image of a dissociative
process in consciousness
and dissociation happens in a way
that can things happen because of
dissociation
as if the brain were a filter
if you see what i mean because the brain
is the image of a dissociate
dissociative process things happen as if
it were a filter
because dissociation is exclusive it
excludes certain things
it creates a boundary and it
differentiates what's in from what's out
and that's like a kind of filtering in
which you let certain things in and you
keep other things
out so things work as if
the brain were a filter and that's the
sense in which i think is useful
but the brain is not literally a filter
because you cannot have
a coffee filter made of coffee and for
the same reason you can cannot have a
filter of consciousness be made of
consciousness
i think it's just an image of a
dissociative process that works as if it
were a filter
and when you say it's an image of a
dissociative process as seen from the
second person on a first person pers
like the first
there's a first person perspective
associated with it one of the
what tripped me up initially and maybe
this will help some other people is that
when we think of mind
we tend to think of our example of mind
within our mind within our head i know
that's you don't like the within our
head aspect
but the way that thoughts relate to
other thoughts
it's volutinous and indistinct and
equivocal
so how could something as precise and
serene as
paper and the natural laws of physics
come from mind
well i guess i'm posing that as a
question but that's my way of saying it
out loud to clarify for some of the
audience members who are wondering how
could this all be in mind
given that our own example of mind is
nowhere near as precise as the
external world seems to be
our individual mind has arisen
from uh evolutionary processes through
cooperation and competition and
competition uh in a in an ecosystem
um and because of that our mind is
largely
uh reactive it works in an impulsive
reactive unstable way because it has
helped us survive
if a tiger would be stalking you
it would help you survive to react very
quickly to any sign
that the tiger might be stalking you
you'd have to react to things
to survive some forms of impulsive
behavior are also
conducive to survival and they allow for
quicker reaction time
reproduction you know it's nice to be
hopelessly
in love with someone that will guarantee
reproduction
so you cannot compare
the dispositions of our human mind
which have been shaped by competitive
and collaborative pressures
through evolution you cannot you cannot
compare the
more or less valuable and
in the and reactive character of our
orientation
to the mentation of a mind that has
never undergone this competitive
pressures
that other mind does not need to react
to an environment
does not need to react to threats does
not need to fall in love
because it's what there is there is
nothing outside it it's what
there was there is and there always will
be so
that mind has no reason to become
reactive and and and and
uh trigger happy uh like our minds is or
valuable
like our like our minds are because it
didn't have to survive an ecosystem and
compete and react
to to external influences so how would
it be
instead it would be exactly what it
seems to be
quite stable unfolding very predictably
according to its own mental archetypes
and we know it's stable because we can
model the behavior of nature
it doesn't change its laws from one day
to the other it seems to behave quite
stably
and what is a stable mind it's an
instinctive mind i'll offer you an
example
even lower animals not too low even
crocodiles
have very instinctive minds that are to
some extent reactive they will react
fast to threats but that fast reaction
is predictable
crocodiles are incredibly predictable
predictable you can you can
measure what distance between them and
you
they have to be at in order to try to
lounge at you
if the distance is higher than that they
will not even try if it's shorter than
that
they are guaranteed to try to lounge at
you and eat you
so instinctive minds are very
predictable
minds in the case of the universe i
think it's distinctive but in addition
to that
it's not reactive either because it's
all there is it doesn't have anything to
have to react
to and that seems to be exactly how it
behaves
what occurs to me right now with this
instinctual metaphor is that
it seems like it there's a bit of
assuming what you're trying to prove
there
so for example let's take a fly and then
you shine some photons on the right side
and then it's wings on the left
move okay the way we explain that is
mechanistically
and without mind traditionally
so then this would be an example of
either demonstrating that the universe
is mechanistic at its core or that
you're saying well
well mind is what is mechanistic but i'm
asking you about the mechanistic aspect
of mind yeah
i i i know exactly where you're coming
from you're saying aren't you
just projecting onto reality what you
expect to see
in reality and you know
it's making a theory unfalsifiable when
you manage to construe every piece of
evidence
in the light of your theory then you
turn it into something
unfalsifiable um some people i mean i am
a believer in evolution by natural
selection i don't think it's
random but i think evolution by natural
selection happens
and some people who are in favor of
evolution by natural selection make it
unfalsifiable because you see
if the bird of paradise has these super
colorful
feathers that make it obvious in an
environment
it's because it attracts mates that way
by making itself very conspicuous
it will attract mates mates will see him
he will be more attractive that's right
but if it's a black bird that you can
hardly see it's boring to death then no
it survives because it's camouflaged and
the predators can see
so you can you can make the theory
unfalsifiable if you go down this path
luckily that's not what we are doing
today to to defend uh
the theory of evolution there are
genetic studies there are experimental
studies
so it runs a little deeper than that but
i am sensitive to this idea of turning
a theory into something unfalsifiable by
interpreting everything favorably
i don't think that is what i'm doing and
i tell you why
if i start from the premises of the
theory everything is mental and we are
part of mind but nature at large is also
mental in nature
what would you expect to be the case
based on what we know about life the
universe and everything
i would be surprised if nature were
valuable unpredictable and reactive
under the framework of my theory
because it wouldn't fit with my theory
because you see
our minds have undergone very different
shaping forces and dynamics than the
mind that has never needed
to undergo evolution so i the theory
suggests or implies that these two types
of mind a dissociated one and a natural
one
should behave very differently because
one has undergone the pressures of
natural selection and the other
didn't so i think what we are observing
is a direct
i i think that the universe is
predictable and behaves itself
differently than our own minds
is what you would expect if the theory
i'm i'm proposing is correct
anything else would sort of contradict
it because then you would say well
how can these minds be the same one has
undergone the pressures of natural
selection and the other hasn't
so by what miracle are they the same it
would be dissonant
it would it wouldn't be nice so i don't
yeah sorry have you thought of a
prediction that is falsifiable for your
framework
of the world your conceptualization of
the metaphysics
i know this is tricky this even plays
strength yeah but i can mention a few
uh they are on the edge of what
technology allows us
to measure uh but i can mention a few um
if we were not aware
of any experiential state
whose richness and intensity
is not directly correlated to the degree
of brain activity
then i would say well it doesn't
immediately falsify my theory
but you know under my theory if if our
individual minds are dissociated
processes then there should be some
mental states that correspond to
reduction of dissociation
therefore less brain activity but enrich
the experience because now you have the
the cognitive inferential links so
the theory would expect that at least
some experiential states would break the
correlation between
regionals of experience and the degree
of brain activity most of them most of
the time they will go together but there
should be some states
in which the reduction of brain activity
is a reduction of the dissociation
itself
i imagine you could say near-death
experience is an example of this no
psychedelics
there are there are thousands there are
lots of examples psychedelics
uh um hyperventilation uh the choking
game erotic strangulation
um um g-force induced loss of
consciousness
um um trans trans states
all of these things brain injury
acquired savann
syndrome collateral damage from brain
surgery
i i can i mean i've done it before i
have
listed like two dozen papers that show
that these are all instances in which
you have
reduced or impaired brain activity
accompanied by enriched experience
while we're on the subject of erotica
association so is there something about
sex that
is actually oneness you know people say
that well i feel one with my partner
it's that actually occurring is it like
the ramified branches of the leaves and
they're coming closer
or is it just a perception of that
oneness never ceases to occur
it's always the case but some activities
may bring you closer to the recognition
of it
and i i have no doubt that sexual
ecstasy
brings you quite close to to the
recognition of the oneness that is the
case all the time it's there all the
time
we just don't sense it clearly we don't
we don't pay attention to it we're not
open to it
and sexual ecstasy sort of brings that
recognition
to you other activities as well but you
know it's not for nothing
that um in the subcontinent there we go
again
um tantra is a spiritual path based on
sexual ecstasy
you know these guys realized something
there
they are onto something can you feel
this oneness without feeling any
euphoria attached that is the opposite
can you feel dysphoria
it i don't think
euphoria is inherent in nature
i think the euphoria we feel when in
close proximity to the recognition of
oneness has to do with the kind of
relief
um because the dissociated state
we are used to it so we don't recognize
it anymore for
how difficult and taxing it is
how much energy it requires to remain
dissociated
and when when we come to the recognition
of oneness it's like
that that natural process sort of
relaxes and allows itself to be what it
naturally
is without that tension that energy that
effort required to mode it in that
particular form
and we register that because of the
contrast as
uh bliss because in comparison
to the taxing state we we are in
by the mere fact that we are alive in
comparison to that it is blissful
but i don't think it's inherently
blissful
in the absence of that contrastual
reference if you know what i mean
okay everyone me and bernardo we have to
go what time is it there bernardo
it's a a quarter of 10 to 10 and i
haven't had dinner yet we are talking
since
uh five o'clock so we're almost five
hours five hours
holy moly well this is probably the best
podcast i've ever
had the pleasure of not only taking part
in but listening to
so oh thank you sir it's an honor then
thank you glad i
contributed to this achievement yeah
thank you thank you
how was it for you it's been fun uh um
if it hadn't been i wouldn't have been
talking to you for five hours so
that's the proof that i think it has
been very constructive
positive and and very enjoyable we'll
take one question if you can write this
quickly
someone named cecily said what's the
relationship between the universal
consciousness
and the platonic realm
i think the motivation for sir rogers
postulation of the platonic realm
is that there seem to be some built-in
dispositions in nature
some built-in patterns of behavior um
and and then he postulates this platonic
realm
to account for those regularities which
he cannot see
in in the mental world alone or in the
physical world alone
um i i don't see the need to make that
distinction i think the regularities he
sees the the platonic principles
so to say are merely the archetypes
of the natural mind the inherent
dispositions or the natural frequencies
of vibration or the inherent harmonics
of the natural mind
which are what they are by virtue of
mind being what it is
in other words you don't need an
ontologically distinct realm to account
for those regularities
they are accounted for by the fact that
mind is what it is
it had to be something and to be
something it has to have certain
properties
and those regularities are those
properties you don't need something
outside mind to account for them
they are what they represent what mind
is
does science require materialism in any
way or does logic plus
information produce the same predictive
power
science has never required materialism
it's uh it's a method of study based on
rational reasoning and most of all
empirical experimentation and
observation
none of this requires any metaphysical
commitment of any sort
because all of this is about how nature
behaves and how we can predict
nature's behavior none of it
implies a commitment to a particular
position about what nature
is in and of itself we cannot
have access to nature as it is in and of
itself
other than the access we have to
ourselves as parts of nature
and on the basis of that access the only
thing we can say is that just
like we are mental beings from within so
is the rest of nature
but science is based on an observation
of behavior
cataloging and modeling the regularities
of nature's behavior
that does not require materialism or
any metaphysical commitment also not
idealism
that can be based on a complete that can
be done
on a complete metaphysical vacuum it's
just that human beings
are not perfect we always need a
metaphysical narrative to inform our
actions
so in practice many scientists work
under the assumptions of materialism
but that is not science that is the
prejudices
of the people who practice science
but science as an ideal method as
defined and enshrined in our culture as
a method
is completely metaphysics agnostic we
don't need any metaphysics
to make science successful i would argue
that it has
much more chances to be successful even
more successful than it already is
if we eliminate metaphysical metaphysics
from it if we keep ourselves really open
to every possibility and just look at
what science can tell us which is the
behavior of nature
we would explore avenues of research
that today we ignore
because our hidden metaphysical
assumptions tell us that they are
impossible and they will produce nothing
well how do we know we never looked at
it
we think they are impossible because of
metaphysical assumptions science would
be better off without any metaphysics
certainly without materialism
thank you bernard get some rest get
something to eat i'm gonna
i have i've been fasting so i'm gonna
break my fast as well
and thank you man it's been quite an
experience i'm grateful to you
it's not been a usual interview i give
three two three four interviews per week
and usually it's the same thing and this
has not been that
so i'm grateful to you thanks so much
i'm grateful to you and hopefully
the mind at large can bless me with a
hairline like yours because i'm balding
don't take yourself too seriously i'm
looking for something so if anyone knows
some treatments for that oh
i'm looking into follicle something
f-u-e we'll see
we'll see okay where can people find out
more about you and
bernardo.com have a good one man
thank you thanks a lot take care bye bye
my backgrounds in math and physics i i
did my undergrad and that
and then i went into filmmaking pretty
much a filmmaker since
and now i've always had something called
you know the theory of everything in the
back of my mind like
first of all i want to get an entire
view of the landscape of theories of
everything
and then pull and make a confection of
my own theory perhaps i won't but at
least i want to understand all the
theories and
give an overview to the audience as well
and that's that's actually
it's not simple at all it's taking
almost all my time so if i seem
like i am tired it's because i don't
know why but well bernardo i can tell
you about this afterwards i had
not a trip but something akin to a trip
that just it sent me in the spiral this
loop of of a panic attack i've never had
a panic attack before
and it had to do with me thinking i'm
crazy because i
heard a voice i thought i heard a voice
like i was half sleeping
so i thought i heard my wife say okay or
yes and she could have
but i don't know if she did and i was
half sleeping anyway and then i thought
am i going crazy and since then for
maybe four weeks ago three weeks ago
i've had trouble sleeping because it's
difficult for me to
sit with my own thoughts and i don't
want to take sleeping medication it's so
addictive so so i've had trouble
sleeping and
and i'm intensely studying for you
intensely studying for some other people
and it's compounding and compounding and
i feel like i'm
wearing myself so thin and
luckily after this i can breathe a big
sigh of relief
because i don't have to prep and maybe
we can even do a part two but just so
you know that's
where i'm coming from in my mind yeah
look these big questions are very
dangerous uh
questions this has been known throughout
the history of humanity
that this is dangerous sacred ground to
tread on
they can be all consuming because they
have to do with what we
really really are and there is vertical
involved in
in even contemplating that space so it's
not surprising that
this has happened to you it has happened
to me has happened to
nearly every worthwhile philosopher for
whom philosopher
philadelphia is a way of life not not
just a job so this
this this is this is known uh although
it may be unfamiliar to you
you're not alone in treading this this
mind feud
thank you thank you that that does help
something that doesn't help is knowing
that people like cantor
drove himself mad by studying infinity
or at least that's what he said
and and i'm i'm wondering how much of
this with me delving into the
depths of reality which is like the
depths of myself as well
is going to bring about psychosis and i
don't want that and i had
an experience once about one and a half
years ago and
what happened was i was typing and then
it said yes you're not the only one
ha i'm here like on its own and i
watched i'm like
shoot is there another part of me and
then i immediately got up and i felt
waves of anxiety
and i had to then i was like shoot i
don't want to feel like this i don't
want to have this experience through the
rest of my life because i have a wife i
love my life
i don't want to be crazy and something
that you mentioned
which is which is known in the
literature is that psychosis is not
necessarily a mental disorder but an
incompatibility
between you and the culture and i can
imagine that people
who if i was to go to a psych ward and
talk to schizos that they would say yes
yes this is not what it is there's no
and then people would think they're
crazy but i would be like no no they're
actually on to something
they're the true enlightened ones it's
just we
who aren't able to accept it and i
didn't want to go to a ward and then i
was like
i don't want another part of my mind to
tell me to kill myself or to kill
someone
and i'm not suicidal in the least but
coming from a place of a different part
of me telling me what to do
i was worried and then i took some
lorazepam to calm me down
and then i i had to go downstairs to the
concierge and say
can you call me an ambulance i was alone
right and then and then they did
they were like freaked out and i was
talking to people saying look i
i know that this sounds crazy i'm not
crazy but i don't want to kill myself
and there's a police officer there at
one point i'm like i just want you to
know i know i don't want to reach for
your gun
i don't know what i'm going to do like
and the police officer was like oh
that's that's fine you're okay you're
okay
and then as soon as the ambulance came
checked my heart i felt calm
but since then i'm like oh man i don't
want to have
i don't want to oh man bernardo man like
i don't want to question reality
but at the same time my job is it like
doing this is
it once you open that pandora's box
you cannot put the demons back the way
to go about it is to learn how to deal
with the demons in a functional way that
doesn't take you out of life in society
but our normal state of consciousness is
adaptive
it's not made to give you access to
truth it's made to
adapt you to the circumstances of our
living even our cultural consciousness
is adaptive well as well it allows you
to get a job to be a reliable
co-worker to be a reliable partner and
father
so i i don't poo poo uh psychotic states
of consciousness as
obviously and true not any more than
this
state of consciousness right now is also
untrue
if you know what i mean i wouldn't go as
far as to romanticize
psychosis as to think that people
undergoing psychosis
are enlightened i think mind has this
proclivity to deceive itself in many
different ways and that's another way of
deception as well could they have access
to
information that is real and to which we
do not
ordinarily have access very well that's
possible yeah it's very all possible
but the important thing is what people
make of it
and that's where people go wrong it's
trying to interpret
that information and weaving a story
about that
that story can be highly dysfunctional
and and deceptive
it can be literally untrue
so we have to make this distinction
between accessing
unthreaded ground in the river of mind
which is just outside the boundaries of
what is functional and adaptive
and interpreting what you access
in those altered states of consciousness
and i think
people tend to go faulty in the
interpretation
it's what people call psychedelic noses
that if they have a hallucination about
talking to aliens in the play ideas they
come back and say well there are aliens
in the play that is very interested in
our
elections and the results of our
political system
well i wouldn't go that far because
mind has this inherent seems to have
this inherent drive to deceive itself
because that's how it creates reality
you